Test, ah, Wackelkontakt, Wackelchamp, warum geht das denn, warum, was ist hier, meiner Verlängerung ist ein Wackelkontakt, Monka, was ist das, was gibt das, was soll das, warum, jetzt, jetzt geht's, hast du Urlaub?
Ne, ich hab montags immer frei, ich geh nie arbeiten montags, das ist schon so ein bisschen das Meme bei uns auf der Arbeit, so nach dem Motto, ah, wie sieht's aus, wenn wir einen Termin montags machen, dann finden sich alle immer furchtbar lustig und kecken sich einen ab, aber da gibt's nix, montags bin ich nicht da, genau, so sieht's aus, übrigens, guck mal, Leak, Handleak, Fingerleak,
ich hab mal wieder,
ich hab mal wieder die Kamera eingeschaltet,
ich will heute probieren, was zu Flashchampen,
mal gucken, wie gut das funktioniert,
bin ich mal gespannt,
weil, hab ich überhaupt
FFZ und Gedöns hier,
Moment, FFZ,
Firefox, es gibt so
gewisse Sachen, die müssen sein, ohne FFZ,
FFZ geht nix,
sag mal, gibt's FFZ nicht,
offiziell
irgendwo,
doch,
ach, Moment, FFZ,
FFZ gibt's nicht mehr bei,
bei Addons,
echt nicht,
na, Franka,
Actual Progchamp,
ach, FFZ gibt es ernsthaft nicht,
ja, ja, ich weiß, ich weiß,
aber warum gibt's das nicht im Addon Store,
muss man nicht verstehen, oder,
Add,
okay,
ja, weil wir brauchen, wir brauchen schon die Emotes,
also ohne die Emotes geht hier gar nix,
Emotes, please,
FFZ,
Moment,
Moment, Moment, Moment,
wir haben Better,
au,
Sekunde,
jetzt wird's, jetzt wird's verwirrend,
Settings, Addons,
Moment, ich hab beides,
ne, wo, wo sind Extensions nochmal,
Manage Extensions,
äh,
ach so,
ich hab Better Twitch TV und FFZ,
ja gut, dann kann FFZ weg, das reicht,
eins, eins reicht,
also sonst zu viel,
heute schauen wir was, äh, äh, ja,
also vor allem, wie man das draufkriegt,
schau mal heute,
warum ist das Stream in 1080p, 48 FPS,
na ja, dass es flüssiger ist,
48 FPS ist halt,
Pog,
kann man FFZ Emotes,
ach ja, ist doch alle Emotes,
sind doch alle, oh, fuck,
jetzt hab ich's zugemacht, lol,
wie ich nicht in der Lage bin, wieder,
das richtig zu machen,
zu bedienen,
Seven, Seven Dings TV, ne,
so, lass mal kurz checken,
ob die Emotes hier drin jetzt ordentlich funktionieren,
ja, passt,
Pog,
genau, für jedes Auge, 24 FPS,
oh ne, Splatoon Musik,
die, die Schrift ist überhaupt nicht,
ja, jetzt erkennt man wenigstens ordentlich was,
so, schieben wir das mal hier oben hin,
ok, also, Chat,
ich hab gedacht, ich mach jetzt mal den Stream an,
weil ich hätte das nicht so gut,
ich hätte das Ganze auch normalerweise ohne Stream gemacht,
ich bin mir gar nicht so sicher, ob man das zeigen darf,
aber ich geh mal stark davon aus,
dass es kein Problem ist,
weil, das kann passieren,
weil Android ist, naja,
ein, prinzipiell ein Open Source Betriebssystem,
und mit irgendwelchen ROMs und Sachen,
verletzt man ja nix,
zumal, äh, XDA ziemlich,
ziemlich, äh, ja, wie soll man sagen,
ziemlich stark reglementiert ist,
was man da anbieten darf und was nicht,
da war,
warum nicht, ich mein, verboten ist es bestimmt nicht,
außerdem haben wir das schon mal gemacht,
verboten ist es nicht,
ich kann mit meinem Tablet machen, was ich will,
zumal,
ähm, was soll ich jetzt sagen,
es ja letztendlich dazu führt, dass die mehr Tablets verkaufen,
mal davon abgesehen,
das ist ein altes,
ein altes Fire HD 10 von 2017,
guckt mal, das ist so eins,
das ist so eins,
und,
das gibt's ja gar nicht mehr,
wahrscheinlich auch,
nicht mal anfällig dafür,
Timchu, dankeschön für den Sub,
exakt dafür will ich's machen,
das ist ja auch der Grund,
Timchu, dankeschön für den Sub,
warum ich, warum ich das haben will,
ich hab ja schon welche,
also ich hab ja schon mehrere hier,
als, äh, Home Automation Dashboard,
und,
ich hätt jetzt gern noch eins,
und ich hab halt noch ein Fire HD 10 von 2017,
deswegen wird das jetzt,
ähm, geflasht, schämt,
es gibt auch die Möglichkeit,
dort so ein paar nervige Sachen auszustellen,
wie diesen automatischen Bildschirmschoner und sowas,
ähm,
aber,
du hast trotzdem Probleme,
du kannst es nicht automatisch entlocken und sowas,
das, also,
geflasht ist tatsächlich die bessere Variante,
bock,
du verdienst noch 70,
kein Fakt, ich hab ein iPad,
aber was soll ich mit dem iPad,
ein iPad bringt dafür überhaupt nichts,
iPad ist so ziemlich das schlechteste Tablet,
was es für Home Automation und Dashboards gibt,
das iPad ist gut,
doch, doch, doch, es gibt auch ein 2021er Variante,
ich glaub, die lässt sich aber nicht flashen,
das iPad ist gut zum normalen benutzen,
aber nicht hierfür,
kann man hier irgendwie bei der Twitch-TV die, die Schrift,
die Font-Size ein bisschen,
Z-Font-Size,
äh, 20?
Boah, oh, keck,
wie viel Vergrößerung haben wir denn hier?
Ah, ist doch gut, da kennt man wenigstens was,
mit was ist denn besser, so mit Farben oder,
ich muss den Dark Reader hier ausmachen,
oh, Monka, so ist gut,
der Prickchamp ist am Start,
ich hoffe nicht, dass es Prickchamped,
also, das erste, was wir machen müssen, ist,
wir müssen das Ding routen,
also, ich hab mir die,
ich hab mir die Anleitung so grob durchgelesen,
jaja, wie, äh, green,
also, was wir machen müssen, ist folgendes,
wir müssen es flashen,
äh, wir müssen es routen,
und,
dann müssen wir irgendwelche komischen Dinger machen,
ich hab keine Ahnung, vielleicht,
vielleicht Prickchamped das dann auch,
ich hoffe nicht,
ich hoffe nicht, dass es kaputt geht,
wenn es kaputt geht, werdet ihr es da sehen, ja,
Prickchamp,
hast du fleißig den ganzen Guide durchgelesen?
Ja, ich habe im Vorfeld schon ein bisschen geguckt,
und da sind Dinger drinne,
die ich etwas,
gibt es Aussetzer?
Wirklich?
Was macht Vodafone?
Sekunde,
ne, keinerlei Aussetzer, nix,
null Dropped Frames, gar nix,
absolut perfect,
ne, sowas mache ich nicht,
man muss ja nicht scammen,
außerdem habe ich die Dinger schon seit 2 Jahren oder so,
was wollte ich jetzt gerade, was wollte ich,
achso, Guide,
ja, da stehen ein paar Dinger drinne,
die mich etwas,
ähm, wie soll ich sagen, beunruhigen,
da steht nämlich drinne,
wenn man eine neue,
ich mach mal kurz ein bisschen größer,
ja,
da steht nämlich drinne,
wenn man eine neuere Firmware hat,
als 5.640,
dann muss man downcraten,
und jetzt kommt's,
this requires pricking
the device temporarily,
tempo, temporarely,
also sprich, man muss sein Device,
kurz vorübergehend kaputt machen,
damit man downcraten kann,
und,
ich hoffe halt,
dass das temporär nicht zu dauerhaft wird, ja,
ich mach mal kurz an,
und wir gucken mal nach,
wir gucken mal kurz nach,
ich mach das mal kurz weg,
ich bin mir nämlich nicht ganz sicher,
ob man am Anfang nicht irgendwie WLAN oder solche Geschichten sieht,
deswegen muss ich mal kurz,
mach ich mal kurz, ähm,
weg,
und dann gucken wir mal kurz die,
die US-Version nach,
ob das passt,
ich hoffe,
ich hoffe, wenn ich's einschalte,
dass es jetzt nicht irgendwelche Updates macht,
und,
dass es dann nicht mehr,
nicht mehr flashbar ist,
so, schauen wir mal kurz,
so,
ist, natürlich sieht man das WLAN,
war doch klar,
also Geräteoptionen,
Systemupdates,
also guckt mal,
diese US-Version hab ich,
erkennt man das?
Boah, Alter, ist das staubig,
schmonka, es sieht gar nicht so staubig aus hier so,
Sekunde,
erkennt man da was?
Das da,
5610,
jetzt ist halt die Frage,
Facelink,
ja, ja, ich weiß,
ähm, kann sein, dass ich mich heute ein bisschen spiegle,
jetzt ist halt die Frage,
ist,
ähm,
wo steht's denn hier?
Jetzt ist halt die Frage,
ist 561,
ist es, warte mal, war es 561,
oder 5610?
Ich hatte 561,
ja,
das heißt, das passt,
das passt,
dann kann ich,
ja, ich hab das seit 2018 oder so nicht,
nicht mehr angehabt,
ich hab fast zwei Jahre,
reicht ja nicht,
seit zwei Jahren ist ja Corona,
das war lang vorher,
das ist, seit 2018 hab ich das,
seit 2018 hab ich den Kempel,
also,
es ist uralt,
ich hab die korrekte Firma,
das ist POG,
so,
jetzt werden wir als erstes mal einen Snapshot machen,
da hab ich noch Platz,
mal kurz, kurz checken,
ah,
sollte reichen,
Snapshot von meiner VM,
und jetzt versuchen wir das Ding mal,
soll ich das mit dem Raspberry Pi machen?
Kann man das ordentlich mit dem Raspberry Pi machen,
hat das jemand schon mal gemacht,
mit dem Raspberry Pi,
funktioniert das?
Weil dann könnte ich's da liegen lassen,
und wir sehen was passiert,
weil ansonsten müsste ich's,
müsste ich's dann quasi hier,
hier rüber,
so da,
in die Richtung an den Rechner stecken,
und dann sieht man nix mehr,
Alter, in der Playlist sind eindeutig zu viele Splatoon Lieder,
ich weiß nicht,
viele feiern den Splatoon Soundtrack,
ja,
aber ich muss ehrlich sagen,
mir gefällt er nicht,
steht da was,
da ist ein Raspberry Pi,
ah,
a factory,
I tried it on my Raspberry Pi,
and it worked,
okay,
andere,
andere machen das,
andere machen das auch mit dem Raspberry Pi,
dann,
dann können,
wir können's auch mit dem Raspberry Pi machen,
dann kommt man vielleicht einfach auch besser dran,
genau,
den,
den Suez,
der Suez wird geroutet,
komm,
ich mach das,
ich mach das mit dem Raspberry Pi,
das ist wahrscheinlich besser,
ich,
ich stell mal die Kategorie um,
wir sind ja nicht just chatting,
wir sind ja Science,
oder?
Chat,
Pfeifherd,
Science,
Wissenschaft und Technik,
ja,
nein,
das ist nicht Programmieren,
ups,
okay,
ähm,
dann machen wir's mit dem Raspberry Pi,
ist,
ist vielleicht gar nicht so blöd,
da muss ich kurz den Raspberry Pi mal holen,
mal gucken,
ähm,
ist da ne Micro SD drin,
ich flash,
ich flashchampe mal kurz neu,
ich weiß nämlich nicht,
was wir da zuletzt drauf gemacht haben,
schadet nix,
ich flash einfach mal schnell neu,
und dann per Netzwerk dran,
und gut,
ist,
äh,
warum hab ich keinen USB-Anschluss mehr frei,
kann ich den hier rausmachen,
ja,
hoffentlich,
blub,
danach HotTube-Stream,
klar,
bin ich da bekannt für,
dann machen wir dann,
so,
erst mal kurz updaten,
schadet nix,
jawoll,
eine Runde updaten,
nie verkehrt,
oh nee,
updaten ist ne blöde Idee,
wenn ich jetzt update,
muss ich rebooten,
wegen Kernel-Update,
ich reboote nicht,
weil wenn ich,
das ist dann,
ah,
Problem mit dem USB-Stick,
so,
lass mal kurz gucken,
wo ist der USB-Stick,
wo hängt er,
hängt er überhaupt irgendwo,
ja,
Chat,
seht ihr,
wo ist der USB-Stick,
MonkaS,
wo ist er,
SDB,
da,
32,
32G,
ja,
das sieht gut aus,
das ist für mich das Gleiche,
das ist eh,
das ist doch eigentlich alles,
nur so,
so eine,
ja,
wie soll man sagen,
so,
rein rhetorische Sache,
Programmieren,
Softwareentwicklung,
äh,
wo fängt das eine an,
wo hört das andere auf,
irgendwo ist das doch alles,
Softwareentwicklung,
so als Überbegriff,
wie soll man denn Coding
und Programmieren unterscheiden,
Coding ist 1 zu 1,
mehr oder weniger,
das,
der englische Ausdruck für,
na gut,
es wäre Programming,
aber trotzdem,
ne,
wo soll da der Unterschied sein,
äh,
SDB sind wir,
also,
dann machen wir mal,
Sudo,
wie heißt das Ding,
Pi Imager,
Imager,
ja,
Chose OS,
wir wollen ein,
wir machen mal ein 32-Bit,
Leute,
weil ich bin mir nicht sicher,
ob das mit 64-Bit,
alles schon gut klar kommt,
also,
wir machen mal ein 32-Bit,
Leute,
weil ich bin mir nicht sicher,
ob das mit 64-Bit,
okay,
Raspberry Pi OS Lite,
32-Bit,
Chose Storage,
32G Micro SD,
Write,
Would you like,
mach,
Moment,
Edit Settings,
Pi,
Moment,
das muss man ja machen,
was ich mega bescheuert finde,
dass die kein Default Passwort,
mehr haben,
ich weiß nicht,
wer sich das ausgedacht hat,
dass es eine gute Idee ist,
selbst Scripting,
ist ja,
Dann ist das auch Programmieren.
Hacker Man.
So, ich muss mal kurz den Switch einschalten.
Das hier müsste...
So viel Kabelsalat.
So, jetzt müsste der Switch angehen.
Und irgendwie so halb auf halb acht hänge ich dann den Raspberry Pi.
Und dann müsste es halbwegs passen.
So, you can continue.
Das ist aber nett.
Vom Flashchamp, dass ich continuen kann.
Machen wir einmal...
Schließt mal mal noch ein Sync hinterher, man weiß ja nie.
So, und jetzt...
Jetzt machen wir mal die Micro-SD-Karte hier rein.
Sag mal, geht euch das auch immer so, dass ihr die immer falsch herum reinmacht?
Zack.
So.
Jetzt brauchen wir hier das Netzwerkkabel.
Also das Netzwerkkabel, das hätte ich nicht ungünstiger...
nicht ungünstiger legen können hier hinten gerade.
Das ist ja...
Netzwerkkabel in Raspberry Pi rein.
USB anschließen.
Ah.
Raspberry Pi sollte starten.
Ich hoffe, man sieht...
Sieht man was?
Seht ihr die LEDs?
Ja, gerade so, ne?
Der sollte jetzt eigentlich was machen.
Gleich booten von der...
Von der Micro-SD.
Was ihn irgendwie nicht großartig interessiert.
Ah, jetzt.
Jetzt bootet er, okay.
Boot Champ.
mal kurz gucken was der raspberry pi für eine ip gekriegt hat raspberry pi wohnzimmer
ist er das könnte der aber durchaus sein raspberry pi wo ist er denn
es müsste eigentlich der hier sein hallo raspberry pi willst du nicht eine ip mal kriegen
was ist das jetzt schon wieder also ohne scheiß der hat echt probleme der hat das letzte mal
schon immer diese probleme gehabt könnt ihr euch noch daran erinnern wo wir fünf mal wo
wir das fünf mal rein und raus gemacht haben bis es funktioniert hat also von der idee her
müsste er eigentlich 138 haben das ist der alte raspberry pi aus dem wohnzimmer macht
er noch was da macht nichts mehr oder jetzt blinkt er ganz merkwürdig
gut da noch ist eigentlich okay jetzt wieder aus also damit wollte ich mich jetzt eigentlich
nicht weiter aufhalten ja da ist er doch es hat aber gedauert kommt man wie lange wie lange wie
lange da jetzt rum gebootet hat gut der raspberry pi muss erst mal naja ssh keygen hups ssh keygen
mir gehört er muss ja immer erst die festplatte das es funktioniert ich habe doch gesagt
eye oder irgendwie y und z oder so habe ich mich dir ernsthaft vertippt jetzt bei oder was ich
glaub's net ich habe mich beim e-mails passwort meine grüße also ich würde jetzt ich habe das
ich habe raspberry purple habe ich vielleicht raspberry pi geschrieben und ein名en egal ich
mal neu. Das geht schneller als hin und her probieren.
Okay, also
Choose OS. Anderes
32-Bit-Light-Storage.
Stehen da. So,
customizen. Also,
guckt mal hier.
Ich schreibe das jetzt mal hier oben rein.
Rasp Berry.
Ja, so. So schreibe ich das da unten
jetzt auch rein.
Das da weg.
Rasp
Berry.
Safe.
Pff. Guckt hier.
Könnt ihr Brut forcen.
Right.
Yes.
Das war ein Akt.
Guck mal, jetzt ist er auch schon gleich viel langsamer im Schreiben.
Mit dem richtigen Passwort.
Während der Flash, wir gucken uns
nochmal schnell die Anleitung an, dass ich dann weiß, was ich
machen muss. Also.
Linux System Aller. Micro-USB-Cable
habe ich am Start. Install
Python 3, PySerial
ADB, Fastboot
DOS, DOS to Unix. Okay.
Für File, äh, für Line-Endings.
For Debian, Ubuntu, something
like this should work. Ja.
Gut, das machen wir. Das gibt's schon erst bei Power.
Extract, Attached, Zip-File
Amonet, Suez
V1, 1, 2, Zip.
Okay.
Enable ADB-Settings.
Start Script.
Ne, wir müssen nicht down-cryden.
Hier muss ich dann die Kamera ausmachen.
Wobei, das ist so klein da. Da seht ihr
wahrscheinlich gar nichts darum.
Ich mach's dann, ich mach's dann
auch ein bisschen größer, sobald, sobald was
passiert. So.
Dann.
When you are back at the initial
setup, you can skip
registration by selecting the WiFi-Network.
Then press cancel
and then not now.
Okay.
Ah, ich soll das initial setup abbrechen. Okay.
Dann macht er ein Factory
Reset und dann kann ich
ADB wieder enablen.
Alles klar.
Ja, wenn er das sagt.
So, continue.
Hoffentlich kann ich jetzt mein
Raspberry Pi anschmeißen.
Ping.
Ah, gucken wir mal, wie der da ist.
So, schauen wir mal.
So, ich lese mal Chat.
Habe ja grad mehr als genug Zeit für.
Die Schriftart passt nicht wirklich
hierzu, oder?
Ah, so ist schon besser.
Erkennt man wenigstens ein bisschen was.
Also.
Layer-8-Problem.
Ja, so sah's aus.
Äh, ich hab nix Spannendes.
Was habt ihr mit dem iPad?
Ach so, rein auf dem
iPad fürs Studium oder so.
Boah, ich weiß nicht.
Da hätte ich auch keinen Bock drauf.
So ein Laptop ist schon nicht verkehrt.
Warum ich das flashe?
Damit ich das ordentlich verwenden kann als
Heimautomatisierungs-Dashboard, was an der Wand hängt.
Wenn die Dinger mit dem, mit diesem
Wie heißt denn das Ding eigentlich von Amazon?
Fire OS?
Ich glaub Fire OS heißt das.
Da kannst du beispielsweise
den Bildschirm nicht,
dauerhaft entlocken und du hast so
einen komischen Amazon-Bildschirmschoner
und sowas.
Das eignet sich einfach nicht dafür.
Ansonsten, ohne Scheiß, muss man ja auch mal sagen,
das Fire Tablet ist richtig gut.
Also.
Normalerweise muss man das weder flashen
noch irgendwie groß anpassen.
Und, sag mal so, die Werbung ist gar nicht
mal so extrem störend.
Es gibt zwar, also es gibt die einen oder anderen
Tricks, wie man die wegkriegt.
Ja, das könnt ihr dann selbst gucken.
Aber preis-leistungsmäßig ist das Fire Tablet
wirklich unschlagbar gut.
Alter, wie lang brauchen
der Raspberry Pi, bitteschön?
Raspberry Pi, auf, mach hinne.
Das Ding hat das letzte Mal schon immer so Probleme gehabt.
Vielleicht, aber ich werd den garantiert nicht wegschmeißen.
Weil, das ist ein Raspberry Pi 4.
Und ihr wisst, was Raspberry Pi 4s aktuell wert sind.
Ich glaube eher, das liegt an der MicroSD-Karte,
die Probleme hat.
Du hast jetzt auch einen neuen Shop.
POG!
Was hast du denn?
Oder was machst du jetzt?
Machst du täglich?
Kannst du tägliches POG champen?
Fully Kiosk, ja, das mach ich auch drauf.
Das hab ich auch gelaufen.
Das ist ziemlich nice.
Aha, wir sind am Start.
Keygen minus R.
Hi, Ed.
Yes.
Aha, jetzt funktioniert's auch.
Lull.
Okay.
Up, Update.
Okay, alles klar.
Dann wollen wir mal...
...anfangen.
Also, was brauchen wir denn, um das Ganze zu Flash champen?
Python 3, Python Serial, ADB, Fastboot, DOS2UNIX.
Alles klar, machen wir doch doch mal.
Erstmal Upgrade.
Schad nix, wenn wir da aktuell sind.
Und dann Up...
Ups.
Software beim fetten Autokonzern.
Nice.
Jetzt eher User Interface oder...
...Microcontroller-Kram oder...
...Auto-Zeug.
Also, ich meine, ich gehe davon aus,
dass die Leute, die das Touch-Display designen,
bei einem Auto,
andere Leute sind,
die irgendwelche Steuerungen programmieren dafür, ja.
Dann hast du's mit der Android-Toolbox ausgeschaltet, alles.
Oder du hast die Standard...
...hast die Version gekauft ohne Werbung.
Wenn das bei dir so ist.
Doch, bin ich.
Bin ich immer noch.
Aber mal gucken, wie lang noch.
Auf Raspberry Pi.
Update.
Gib ihm.
Okay.
Also.
Up, Install.
Machen wir ein paar Dinge ab, von denen ich...
...weiß ich nicht...
...wo ich denke, dass man die vielleicht braucht.
Es könnte auch sein,
dass ich mit der Toolbox Auto-Updates ausgeschaltet hab.
Da hab ich Glück.
So, jetzt rebooten wir einmal noch
und dann können wir endlich anfangen.
Mal gucken.
So, ist er wieder da?
Nope.
Er bootet echt 5 Stunden von der Micro-SD-Karte.
Wie kann das sein?
Das ist normalerweise super zackig.
Der blinkt auch.
Ich weiß, warum.
Ich weiß, warum das so lange dauert.
Ich hab den umgestellt, dass der über USB-SSD bootet.
Das heißt, der muss jetzt erstmal time-outen.
Der muss jetzt erstmal time-outen, dass er überhaupt von der Micro-SD-Karte anfängt.
Das würd's natürlich erklären.
So, auf geht's.
Also, was müssen wir jetzt machen?
Erstmal das Ding routen.
Hier, den Krempel installieren.
Peißen.
Das ist doch schon alles drauf, oder?
Keck.
Du wirst sehr gewundert.
Ja, ja.
Komm, wir machen das Ganze also.
Gut.
Tut gut.
Hat er irgendwas nicht gefunden?
Nope.
Erstmal die ganzen Krempel als Abhängigkeiten interessieren.
Has anyone an idea to embed H264 into MP4 container?
Yes, you can use FFmpeg.
It should be relatively easy.
Something like this.
FFmpeg.
Minus I.
Your input file.
Copy.
Nee.
Copy?
Ich bin mir gar nicht sicher.
Wie geht denn das?
FFmpeg.
Copy.
Ja.
Minus C.
Copy.
Output.
Output MP4.
Minus.
This should work.
Without transcoding, re-encoding.
Oh.
You can accept an input stream with FFmpeg.
Ja macht das.
Tablets, die HD-Tablets sind POC also wo sind wir, wo sind wir stehengeblieben?
Also, wir haben den Klappen bestellt.
Also, wir haben den Krempel installiert und jetzt soll ich was? Download Extract, Attached Zip. Wo ist die Attached Zip?
Moment, Moment, Moment. Was für eine Zip? Wo ist es? Wo ist das Attached? Muss man dafür registriert sein?
Das da? Das da, hä? Ne, hat es downgeloadet. Achso, Moment. Ich musste auf meinem Raspberry Pi downloaden.
Copy Download Link. Excellent.
Index HTML. Ja, genau das. Das ist das, was ich haben will. Copy. Alter. Copy. Link. Jetzt. Hoffentlich geht das jetzt.
Index HTML. Warte mal. Ist das vielleicht die Datei? Das ist die Datei. Die heißt einfach Index HTML jetzt. Ja, super.
Index HTML. Kekkel. Zip.
Zip. Zipaded, Alter.
Warte mal hier kurz. Ja, Flash Champ.
Okay, Unzip. Okay, so. Und jetzt?
Enable ADB in Developer Settings. Alles klar.
Ich mach mal kurz hier das Tablet ab, weil wir müssen es dann eher im Raspberry Pi stecken.
Okay, in Developer Settings. Chat, weiß jemand aus dem Kopf noch, wie das geht mit Developer Settings?
Man geht irgendwie auf...
Auf Hilfe?
Ne.
Man geht auf Geräteoptionen, Entwickleroptionen und dann muss man neunmal irgendwie draufdrücken.
Ah ja.
Die sind Entwickler.
Leute, habt ihr das gehört? Ich bin offiziell... Amazon sagt das. Ich bin offiziell Entwickler jetzt.
Entwickleroptionen.
Und jetzt?
ADB aktivieren.
Excellent.
So.
ADB ist aktiviert.
Und jetzt schließen wir das Ding mal an den Raspberry Pi an und gucken mal, was abgeht.
Wenn überhaupt was abgeht.
Schließen wir mal einen USB-2-Port an.
Man weiß es ja nie.
So.
Angeschlossen ist es.
Fire mit schwachem Ladegerät verbunden. Ja, das ist mir egal.
Egal, ob ich mit einem schwachen... Oh, man sieht mich.
Leak, Leute. Leak.
Ja, wird schon passen, denke ich.
Okay.
Man sieht Chico auf dem Bild.
Welches HD10 ist das von 2017?
So, und jetzt? Okay, ich hab ADB an.
Hat er das jetzt auch erkannt?
Amazon. Hier. Da.
Zack. Serial Number. Das sieht gut aus.
So, und jetzt geh ich wo rein?
Enable Start Script.
Hier wahrscheinlich, oder?
Step 1. SH.
Na, als Sudo brauchen wir nicht. Wir sind schon gut.
Was passiert denn da überhaupt? Wir gucken mal da kurz rein, was der...
Alter, was? Wie?
Anzeige ist raus, Alter. Kein Wim drauf.
Wichtigste überhaupt.
Ganzen Nano-Kex.
Wim, Step 1. Was macht denn der da überhaupt?
Es hält sich in Grenzen, oder?
Okay.
Step 1. Not running.
Oh. Ich sollte nicht so viel Enter drücken. Wer weiß, was da passiert.
Okay.
Ich will now reboot into recovery.
Seht ihr irgendwas?
Ich seh da nix.
Ah, Moment.
Ich muss erst USB-Debugging zulassen.
Was?
Was will das Ding von mir?
Script, was willst du mir sagen?
It's only for Suess.
Your device is Suess.
Suess und gleich Suess.
Kann es sein, dass ich das schon mal geroutet habe, oder so?
This is a new line, Suess.
Ich glaube, das ist verwirrt, das Skript, oder?
Ich meine, unabhängig davon, ob ich Root habe oder nicht.
Was?
If you are already rooted, continue with next step.
Otherwise, get MTKZU by from here and place binary in Amunet bin.
Ach, das hätte ich vorher machen sollen, oder was?
Das hätte ich vorher machen müssen.
Okay, das ist natürlich Pfeifertag.
Nein, das habe ich nicht gelesen.
Also, ich muss was?
Ich muss das da...
Binary.
Für was?
Monka, was muss ich jetzt alles machen?
Gar nicht.
Einfach nur das Binary runterladen, oder?
Wo ist das Binary?
Hier, Release.
Alles klar.
Ach, ich kack, Noob.
Copy Download Link.
Okay, also.
Nach bin muss ich jetzt.
Ach, da ist das nicht.
Okay.
Index.
Index HTML, alles klar.
Unzip.
Wir unzippen jetzt den Index HTML.
Easy.
Äh.
Und wo hat der jetzt was?
Wo hat der jetzt was entpackt?
Was muss ich, was muss ich denn da jetzt moven?
Welche, welche, welche, welche muss ich denn da jetzt moven?
Oder, oder einfach das gesamte.
Unpacked Binary.
Nee.
Ich glaube.
Step 1?
Nee.
So funktioniert das nicht.
Ähm, ist das jetzt für die Ziel-Plattform oder für meine Plattform vom Raspberry Pi?
Ähm.
Probieren wir es nochmal.
Jetzt sollte es ja gehen.
Ah.
Your device will be reset to factory defaults.
Press Enter to continue.
Leute, ich habe ein bisschen Schiss, dass man irgendwas sieht von meinem Amazon-Account oder so.
Ich, ich zeige es euch nicht.
Ich presse jetzt Enter, ohne dass ihr das seht.
Was?
No device emulators fahren.
Das ging jetzt ja nicht so, nicht so schnell, oder?
Pricked.
Das hat überhaupt nicht rebooted.
Der hat richtig chibated.
Der hat überhaupt nichts rebooted.
Oh.
Jetzt, jetzt hat er rebooted.
Der weiß auch nicht so genau, was er macht, oder?
Rebooting into recovery.
Okay, Leute.
Hier, er rebooted.
Guckt mal da.
Seht ihr?
Er rebooted.
Reboot champ.
Und wie geht es jetzt weiter?
Der macht jetzt, okay, der macht factory reset.
Das ist jetzt erst einmal langweilig champ.
Start script.
Device will into recovery and perform a factory reset.
Bla, bla, bla.
Das haben wir nicht.
When you are back at initial setup.
Okay, er rebooted weiter.
Guckt hier, er ist am Reboot champen.
Ich muss auf jeden Fall wieder ADB re-enablen, sonst funktioniert es nicht.
Schauen wir mal.
Gucken wir mal, ne?
Also, aktuell macht er nichts, außer zu resetten.
Optimizing system storage.
This will take approximately 10 minutes to complete.
Ja, das ist aber krasse Optimierung, die hier läuft.
Massive optimizing.
Ich glaube nicht wirklich, dass es 10 Minuten braucht.
Da steht bloß was von 10 Minuten, dass die Leute nicht gleich bei der Hotline anrufen nach 30 Sekunden.
Wobei es gibt keine Hotline, aber ihr wisst, was ich meine.
Okay, das muss ich.
Da muss ich dran denken.
Ich muss ADB re-enablen.
Ganz wichtig.
ADB muss re-enabled werden.
Kennt man da irgendwas drauf?
Ja, er optimized.
Guckt, er optimized system storage.
Genau, ADB re-enable nicht vergessen.
Mach ich gleich.
Sobald er fertig optimized ist.
Auf, gib ihm.
Nicht Amazon.
Google, mach hin.
Optimize mal schneller.
Muss wahrscheinlich noch die restlichen Sachen schnell in die Cloud hochladen, bevor er es resettet.
Massive exciting.
Warte, Fortschrittsbalken zugucken.
Hey, guck mal.
Er ist schon bei 40%.
Das ist doch Schwachsinn, was da steht, oder?
Der macht doch sicherlich was ganz was anderes, als System Storage und Applications zu optimizen.
Das ist wahrscheinlich der Reset.
Da steht bloß irgendwas da, wo sich die Leute drüber freuen können.
So nach dem Ausdruck, oh, es macht mein Tablet schneller.
Ja.
Das ist so wie mein Vater.
Der hat sich früher immer Tune-Up-Utilities 2005 und Zeug installiert.
Falls jemand diesen Blödsinn kennt.
Und hat's, oh, was halt, nee, 2005 so.
1995, 1995.
Tune-Up 95 und sowas hat er sich installiert.
Und dann war er der Meinung, es geht gar nicht ohne mehr.
Also, sein PC wäre so langsam ohne.
Da würde ich mir mal Gedanken machen.
Wird das eine Installation mit Micro-G?
Okay, das weiß ich noch nicht genau.
Erstmal muss ich's routen.
Ich brauch keine Google-Services.
Ich brauch F-Droid danach.
Eventuell den Aurora-Store für den Kiosk-Browser.
Dann müsste ich die Lizenz für den Kiosk-Browser umziehen auf das neue Tablet.
Aber das hat's ja zum Glück einen guten Trial-Modus.
Wie sieht's aus, Optimizer?
Okay, ah, 70%, hä?
Oder? Zeig mal.
Ja, ja.
Ist fast fertig.
Fast durch.
Guck hier.
Hat's fast geschafft.
Bei einer rotierenden HDD.
Also, Tune-Up 95 hat, glaube ich, wenig gebracht, was Festplatte angeht.
Du konntest die defragmentieren.
Ansonsten, was willst du großartig machen bei einer HDD, außer defragmentieren?
Oh, oh, er ist fertig, Leute.
Er ist fertig.
Lull.
Amazon will Zeug von mir haben.
Also.
United States.
US.
Ja, ja, Kekona.
Eindeutig.
Continue.
Back.
Wie hat er gesagt, geht das hier mit dem Setup?
Irgendwas stand doch hier mit Setup.
When you are back at initial setup, you can skip registration by selecting a Wi-Fi-Network,
then press cancel and then not now.
Okay, Wi-Fi-Network, cancel, not now.
Ah, skip Fire-Setup, skip Six-Head, Alter.
Okay, es ist ziemlich veramazonifiziert wieder.
So, und jetzt muss ich ADB wieder anmachen.
Machen wir.
Device Options.
Sie sind now ein Developer.
Hoho.
Sind wir geil, wir sind ein Developer, Leute.
Yes, USB-Debugging aktiviert.
Okay, alles klar.
Und jetzt geht's weiter mit Step 2.
Now flash your device will reboot into TWRP.
Oh, jetzt wird's ernst, Leute.
Step 2.
Brick Champ.
Bye-bye, HD10.
Okay, es bootet, Leute, es bootet, es bootet.
Was?
Macht's sonst noch irgendwas?
Kurz gucken.
Nee, aktuell...
Oh, was ist das?
Oh, was ist hier los?
Das kann ich nicht lesen.
Sekunde.
Oh, Five-Head-Time ist hier angesagt.
Guckt mal hier.
Warte mal, ich dreh's mal so, dass ihr es lesen könnt.
Das Problem ist, wenn ihr es lesen könnt,
wenn ihr es lesen könnt, kann ich es nicht lesen.
Tja.
Okay, also, was haben wir jetzt?
T-WRP can leave your system partition unmodified.
To make it easier for you to take official updates,
you will be enabled, prevent the stock from replacing...
Aha.
Okay, meinetwegen.
Und wie geht's jetzt weiter?
You can now install Magisk from there.
Was sagt mir das jetzt?
Was?
Ich kann Magisk...
installieren.
Will ich Magisk überhaupt?
Oder war's das jetzt?
Ist es jetzt...
fertig?
Going back to stock?
Das brauch ich nicht, oder?
Magisk.
Das heißt, das war's jetzt.
Oh, ist es jetzt ausgegangen?
Ah, nee, geht noch.
So, you can now install...
Will ich ja gar nicht.
Ich glaub, wir müssen jetzt hier weitermachen.
Was will der eigentlich grad von mir?
Was ist das?
Swipe to unlock.
Massive.
Ich glaube, es geht jetzt weiter mit der anderen Anleitung.
This ROM only works on devices using the bootloader hack.
Ja, das haben wir jetzt ja gemacht.
Das haben wir jetzt ja gemacht.
Do not update Magisk.
Aha.
Kein Magisk.
Wir lassen Magisk weg.
Also.
Downloads Google Drive.
Okay.
Äh.
Und wie installiere ich das jetzt?
Was davon brauche ich jetzt?
Also meine bisschen Anleitung wäre ja vielleicht nicht verkehrt gewesen.
Und wie geht das jetzt?
Oder muss ich doch hier noch weitermachen?
Nee.
Also, Google Drive.
So, hier.
Moment.
Ja.
Wir wollen haben...
Was ist das zuletzt geänderte?
Hier, 5.7.
Da.
Wollen wir haben.
Das da.
Äh.
Hallo?
Kann man Google Drive nicht irgendwie den Link über den Rechtsklick bekommen?
Muss ich jetzt allen Ernstes den X-Forwarding machen, dass ich da über den Browser downloaden kann, oder was?
Keck.
Ich fasse es nicht.
Muss ich Chrome installieren?
Dass ich...
Okay, ich könnte es auch runterladen und rüber SCPen.
Das wäre klar.
Warum mache ich es eigentlich so kompliziert?
Ich kann es einfach runterladen.
Ich kann es einfach nur rüberkopieren.
Egal, wir machen X-Forwarding.
X-Forwarding sieht immer stylisch aus.
So, und was ist hier in diesem anderen Ordner drinne?
TWRP?
Ich meine, vielleicht hat er eine Anleitung hier auf GitHub.
Nee.
Raspberry Pi.
Komm, installiere mal.
Weil so ein Chrome ist ja wahrscheinlich mit allen Abhängigkeiten auch mal 800 MB oder sowas groß.
Brauchst schon kurz.
Du, du, du, du, du, du, du.
Chat mir ist es jetzt einfach mal danach.
So, genug.
Und jetzt wieder...
Mensch, mach hier ne.
Weil ihr seid, Chat.
Weil ihr seid.
So, jetzt aber gut.
Jetzt Gnome installieren.
Du meinst, den scheiß Gnome soll ich installieren?
Die Weebs sind happy.
So muss das sein.
Also.
Jetzt, 96%.
Komm, mach.
Unrundead, dankeschön für den Sub.
Leute, falls ich Subs übersehen hab, sorry, tut mir leid.
Ich weiß alle Subs zu schätzen.
Oder wie sagen die Ami-Streamer immer?
Ich appreciate das.
Das klingt so richtig cringe auf Deutsch.
So, machen wir SSH-Y
und gucken, ob jetzt
der Chrome aufgeht.
Hey, wir haben nen Chrome auf Raspberry Pi auf.
Boah.
Massive Poke.
Oh,
huge Geschwindigkeit im Browser.
Also das hier,
dieser Browser jetzt, nur,
damit ich euch nicht verwirre,
dieser Browser hier, der läuft auf dem Raspberry Pi.
Nur die Grafikausgabe
ist bei mir.
Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt hier was runterlade,
dann landet das auch
auf dem Raspberry Pi.
Also nicht auch
auch, sondern auch nur
auf dem Raspberry Pi.
Das ist das Wunder der Technik.
Ja, es ist leider relativ langsam,
das Wunder der Technik.
Also X-Forwarding ist nix,
womit man schnelle Sachen machen möchte.
Aber es geht.
Dafür geht es auch von VMs aus Indien.
So.
Ist das eigentlich Lineage oder Lineage?
Das ist runtergeladen.
Sudo.
Okay, wie geht's jetzt weiter?
Wie flashe ich jetzt was?
Chat, ihr müsst mir helfen.
Ich hab wirklich keine Ahnung, wie das funktioniert jetzt.
Ich hab jetzt, ich hab jetzt den ROM
hier drauf.
Okay.
Wir machen jetzt, Chat, ihr dürft
jetzt backseaten. Das dürft ihr sonst
nie. Jetzt dürft ihr das.
Okay.
Also.
Ich hab jetzt geswiped, um Modifications
zu erlauben.
So. Geswiped, um Modifications
Was mach ich jetzt? Mount?
Ah, das sieht man schlecht, ne?
So. Hier, viel besser.
So. Excellent. So machen, dass man was sieht.
So. Mount.
Select Partitions to Mount.
Da ist keine Anleitung.
Mount System Partition. Ne.
Ich will flashen. Das ist richtig. Ich will flashen.
Ich will flashchampen.
Also will ich, will ich
install machen.
Install Image. Ne.
Die Datei ist nicht auf dem Tablet. Ne.
Ne, ne. Ich hab, ich hab
das ROM hab ich hier.
Moment.
Home, Pi, Downloads,
das da.
Mounten, um rüber zu kopieren. Okay.
Leute, das ist jetzt ein bisschen kompliziert für mein Hirn,
weil ich navigiere über die Kamera.
Das heißt links ist eigentlich gar nicht links,
wie ich meine Hand bewegen muss.
Also doch. Mount.
Data Cache Storage.
Also.
Storage?
Ne.
Das ist schon gemountet, oder wie?
Und muss ich jetzt mit ADB
irgendwas kopieren?
Einfach in Pi das Tablet mounten.
Moment.
Ach so.
Ne.
Ach. Ne.
Das ist was anderes.
Ich hab hier nix zum Mounten. Ich hab nur meine SD-Karte.
Also hier
ist nix zum Mounten.
Hm. Der hat aber erkannt.
Der hat aber irgendwas erkannt hier.
Okay.
ADB Mount?
Ne.
Okay, das kann nicht so schwierig sein, Leute.
Das kriegen wir schon raus.
Select Storage.
Internal Storage.
Was ist MTP?
Media Transfer Protocol.
Chat, das kriegen wir raus.
So schwer kann das nicht sein.
Ich mein, ich brauch im Prinzip hier einfach nur ne Disk.
Was unter
Advanced Sideloaden?
Okay, Pfeiffer Chat.
Advanced
ADB Sideload.
Swipe
to start Sideload.
Der Chat ist
wieder MVP hier. Guck, jetzt haben wir
Sideloaden aktiviert.
Und jetzt macht man was?
ADB
Sideload.
Aber am Moment muss man das erst anzippen.
Lädt man das als
Zip, den ROM?
Oder anzippt man das vorher?
Nicht anzippen.
Okay.
ADB Sideload.
Aha.
Und jetzt?
Boah. Alter.
Was ist das für ein Speed?
Naja, okay.
Komm, wir sind bei 10%.
Es ist gar nicht so langsam, wie ich gedacht hab.
Wir sind bei 10%.
Wir haben jetzt ne halbe Minute. Das geht.
Fünf Minuten sind wir fertig.
Du-du-du-dü-dü-dü.
Was, bei MTP ist das schneller?
Nee, das ist
wahrscheinlich wegen USB.
Einfach, das ist USB 2.
Ich glaub, mehr hat das Tablet gar nicht.
Wollen wir mal kurz schauen, was das Tablet hat.
Ich glaube ich hab nur ein USB 2 Kabel dran.
Ich dachte, das reicht.
Fire HD 10 2017.
Specs.
Alter, was sind das für Scamseiten.
USB.
Na ja, nur USB 2.0. Ja, dann ist klar, warum das so langsam ist.
Also Leute, ich bin wirklich relativ planlos.
Warum hat er hier irgendwelche TWRP-Versionen hingeschmissen, wenn ich doch TWRP hier schon installiert habe?
Oder muss das irgendwie geupdatet werden oder sowas?
Du kannst TWRP auch updaten. Warum? Bringt mir das was?
Ich glaube, die gehen einfach von aus, jeder Noob weiß, wie man in Android flasht, aber ich habe keine Ahnung.
Aber wir werden es ja gleich wissen. Guck mal, 35% schon. Easy.
Geht doch richtig zackig.
Leute, wir dürfen einfach nicht zugucken, dann geht es schneller.
Geblockt. Progress blockt. Aha, so ist das also.
Achtung, ha, wer hat es gesehen? Die Prozent sind scheiße, genau.
Und?
Es ist, guckt Leute, wir haben nicht hingeguckt und schon ist es fertig. Easy.
Also weiter geht's, weiter geht's.
Back, back.
So, jetzt müsst ihr mir wieder sagen, ich vermute mal install, oder? Install wahrscheinlich, install.
Alter, wo hat er das jetzt hingepackt?
Über Sideload hast du das komplett geflasht.
Ach so, ach wirklich?
Der flasht das direkt.
Da muss ich nichts mehr auswählen, oder wie?
Ach so.
Na dann, easy.
Was soll ich noch wipen? Aber lösche ich das dann nicht wieder, was ich gerade geflasht habe?
Oder wipt das nur quasi die Settings und nicht das Image?
Okay, wipe.
Was steht da?
Most of the time, the only wipe that you need.
Okay.
Äh, was?
Was soll ich jetzt swipen oder Format Data sagen?
Swipen oder Format Data?
Was will der jetzt von mir?
Advanced?
Ich hab doch vorher ein Factory Reset gemacht, warum sollte ich da irgendwas swipen?
Muss da bestimmt nichts swipen.
Okay, ich muss das mal kurz so machen, dass ich was lesen kann da drauf.
Haken bei Art, Cache, Data und dann...
Cache, Data, Quatsch.
Quatsch.
Also Wipe, wenn du von Stock zu Custom gehst.
Okay.
Art, Data, Cache, also so.
Ja?
Pass auf, jetzt ist gleich geprickt.
Und jetzt, und jetzt wird geswiped.
Jetzt wird geswiped.
Wie, das war's?
Reboot, und jetzt Reboot?
Reboot, und dann sollte er den ROM starten?
Da bin ich mal gespannt.
Und jetzt Brick Champ.
Da startet irgendwas von Amazon, das ist glaube ich immer das gleiche beim Starten.
Bricked.
Ne, macht das...
Ist das jetzt schon an?
Nö.
Vielleicht braucht es auch einfach noch ein bisschen.
Force Champ.
Ich hab doch vorher gewiped.
Genau nicht hingucken, Chat.
Wir müssen... Moment, ich muss das abdecken.
Ich hab doch gewiped, Chat.
Wir waren jetzt einfach...
Guck mal, ich mein, mehr als kaputt ging.
Ich kann's ja nicht.
Moment, steht da überhaupt noch irgendwas drauf jetzt?
Zeigt mal kurz her.
Warte mal, unten steht Fast Boot Mode.
Oh, ich glaub, das ist schlecht, oder?
Fast Boot Mode steht unten.
Nicht schlecht, nur der falsche Modus.
Was auch immer.
Ach, soll ich vielleicht mal...
Vielleicht, weil das noch per Android Debug-Zeug dran ist.
Vielleicht, weil der noch irgendwie Amazon-Tablets...
Weil der jetzt noch erkannt hat, dass das...
Okay, ich zieh mal das Kabel ab.
Und dann schalten wir mal aus.
Gucken, was passiert.
Ne?
Gucken wir mal.
Ah.
Und jetzt?
Da steht jetzt Amazon.
Amazon.
Sollte da nicht eigentlich...
direkt das Lineage-Logo kommen zum Starten?
Oh, oh, Leute!
Es bootet!
Guck dir mal.
Ja. Easy.
Doch nicht.
Doch nicht gebrickt.
Okay.
Jetzt schließe ich's mal zu...
Na gut, geladen hab ich ja schon auf 50%.
Eins vor Brick.
Okay, das Booten dauert wirklich ewig.
Gleich Kernel-Panic.
Gibt es eigentlich noch irgendwelche anderen
Custom-Sachen außer Lineage-OS,
was man so kennt und wo es für andere...
Wobei, das bringt mir ja nix, wenn's sowas gibt.
Es müsste irgendjemand
einen ROM gebastelt haben dafür.
Guck mal, guck mal, es ist gebootet.
Es ist...
Es ist gebootet.
Was? Calyx-OS. Was?
Nie gehört.
Noch nie gehört.
Ist das jetzt fertig? Muss ich jetzt was machen?
Ah!
Next.
Äh, Englisch.
United Kingdom. Jawohl.
Kekona. Ne, United States.
Kekona.
Hell yeah, Kekona.
Okay.
Ich muss jetzt nur gucken.
Ich will keine WLAN-Sachen leaken.
Your time zone.
Wie wär's mit Europe?
Sowas Berlin?
Ja. Date, Time, alles gut.
Okay, WiFi-Network.
So, ihr könnt erst wieder gucken,
wenn ich mich WLAN-verbunden hab.
WLAN-Passwort, okay.
Da muss ich kurz nachgucken
auf dem zweiten Bildschirm.
Kein Leak, ne.
Ich kann mir mein WLAN-Passwort
immer noch nicht merken.
Das ist auch zu lang mittlerweile.
Aber es sind normale Wörter, also...
WLAN...
Okay, da kommt schon mal WLAN drinne vor.
Das ist schon mal gut.
So, wenn ich mich jetzt nicht verschrieben hab,
sollte es funktionieren.
Obtaining IP.
POG.
Okay, nice.
Next.
Location Service.
Protect your Tablet mit einem Pin.
Ha, keck.
Will ich nicht.
Start.
Okay.
Ha.
Nice. Ich glaub es funktioniert.
Ich glaube das geht einfach jetzt.
Guckt mal.
Ich glaube das ist einfach jetzt...
Das tut jetzt einfach.
So, jetzt brauch ich...
Ich brauch nur eine App da drauf.
Und das ist...
Na gut, ich brauch Chrome.
Das heißt ich brauch auf jeden Fall Google Shit.
Also, wie macht man das jetzt?
am ehesten. Also
normalerweise, sagt mir mal, ob das
Sinn ergibt. Normalerweise
würde ich, genau, normalerweise würde ich mir
jetzt F-Droid draufhauen und noch den
Aurora Store draufhauen.
Wieso Chrome? Weil Chrome WebRTC
kann. Äh, nee, ich brauch nicht
Chrome. Stimmt doch gar nicht.
Ich muss den Android WebView aktualisieren.
Nicht
Chrome in Sinn. Ich muss den Android
WebView aktualisieren. So was.
Nicht Chrome, blödsinnig.
Das brauch ich, weil der neue WebRTC
kann. Letztendlich ist unter
Android das meiste auch Chrome.
Okay, ähm, das heißt
wir installieren
jetzt mal
Hab ich da einen Browser drauf? Irgendwas?
Ja.
Ich hab den eingebauten Android Browser.
Sag mal,
das war ne blöde Frage, Chat.
Aber, also,
ich mein, ich bin nicht so ne Android-Kenner,
ja? Was ist denn hier
das Start? Was ist denn hier eigentlich das Start?
Startmenü. Normalerweise ist das Startmenü
hier in der Mitte das, ja?
So, da. Aber das ist
der Browser. Hat das ein Startmenü?
Dass ich sehen kann, was alles installiert ist?
Wahrscheinlich.
Hochwischen.
Ach so, alter,
Mann. Das ist aber auch laufend irgendwas
anderes, oder? Hochwischen
muss man. Okay, Browser.
Okay, so.
Da installieren wir jetzt den
F-Droid Store. Ich kann so nicht tippen,
das funktioniert nicht.
Ich verwende normalerweise kaum Android-Geräte.
Ich hab nur welche an der Wand hängen.
So, F-Droid.
Allow.
Gut. Oh.
Der Download hat nicht funktioniert.
Alter, wenn ich nach
F-Droid Store suche, kommt als erstes
Queen Elisabeth. Was hatten die
damit zu tun?
Okay, so, Download ist fertig.
Sag mal, die Downloads sind dann hier wahrscheinlich,
ne? Unter Files, geh ich mal von aus.
Ups. Downloads.
Ah ja, hier, guck da.
F-F-Droid.
Und was will der von mir?
Das kann doch keiner lesen, alter.
Your tablet personal data
are more valuable.
Ja, ja.
Yes, install
application.
App installed.
Open.
So.
Update repositories.
Oh, ganz schön lang für.
Wieso das nicht schon dabei ist?
Keine Ahnung.
Okay. Aus irgendwelchen Gründen
kann der nix updaten. Das ist auch geil.
Also, das von unten wischen, muss ich
mich wirklich noch dran gewöhnen.
Das ist ziemlich six-headig.
Updating repositories.
Guck mal.
Der ist ganz schön fleißig,
fleißig am Downloaden.
Okay, das dauert jetzt.
Gib ihm.
Nein, nein, nein, nicht ausgehen.
Alter.
Oh, jetzt hat er es gecheckt.
Okay, search Aurora Store.
Hier.
Install.
Kennst du? Ja, das kenne ich.
So, und danach kann ich
mein System Chrome, Chrome View,
was ich mit WebRTC vorhabe.
Ich will die Kameras
beispielsweise anzeigen. Wenn es bei mir an der Tür
klingelt, switcht er automatisch auf die Kamera
von Hoftor und
Hof.
Das geht über WebRTC.
Warum noch ein Store?
Ja, dass ich das Zeug installieren kann, was nicht
über F-Droid geht.
So, next, next,
next, next,
S. Alter, ich komme
mir echt vor wie der letzte Mensch.
Äh, finish.
So, log in.
So, und jetzt brauche ich nämlich,
jetzt muss ich den, den WebView
aktualisieren, weil der garantiert uralt ist.
Android System
WebView.
Auf irgendeine aktuelle, auf irgendeine aktuelle
Chrome-Version.
So, und dann müsste
eigentlich alles funktionieren.
Ich glaube, das war's dann.
Do you want to install this application?
Yes.
War das jetzt installiert oder nicht?
Open, ja.
Okay, pork. So, alles klar.
Dann probieren wir das mal aus. Ich starte mal meine
Home Assistant, meine Home Assistant VM hier.
Ich meine, ich werde, ich mache es jetzt nicht,
ich mache das jetzt nicht mit meiner, meinem
echten Home Assistant, weil ihr da zu
vielen Sachen seht und so viel, zu viele
Leaks hat oder haben und alles.
Aber das Tablet mal ordentlich integrieren
können wir jetzt ja mal machen.
So, ich werde jetzt die App noch installieren
hier.
Ah ja, Reboot, gib ihm.
Oh, hier, beste VM.
Reboot. Set.
Ja. Guckt mal.
Das da werde ich jetzt noch installieren.
Fully, Fully Kiosk Browser.
Der hat mittlerweile sogar eine Home Assistant Integration.
Werde ich euch gleich zeigen.
Do you want to install this application?
Yes.
Open.
Sehr schön.
So, alles klar, da sind wir.
Got it.
Okay, dann starten wir mal unseren Home Assistant und können das dann mal
integrieren. Ach so, ha, ne Fireball-Technik komme ich da gar nicht hin mit dem Tablet.
Aber das, na gut, das macht nix.
Ich zeige, ich schalte das mal frei.
Ich zeige es euch trotzdem.
Ähm, ach so, welche IP hat denn mein, mein Tablet eigentlich?
Sieht man das hier in den, in den Wifi Settings irgendwo?
More Settings?
Hm, Advanced?
Aha, 122 hat das.
122.
Raspberry Pi, da muss man ein bisschen weg, da ist ein bisschen Platz für das Tablet ist.
Das Ding braucht nämlich eine feste IP.
Ja, 122, alles klar.
Passt.
Ja.
Die sind jetzt rootbar, aber das ist ein 2017er, was ich habe.
So, das ist mein Android Tablet.
Uh, Alter.
High, High Performance Wi-Fi.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Alter, wie schlecht.
Guck mal an, wie langsam ist der, bitteschön.
Was ist denn mit dem WLAN in dem Ding los?
Es ist ja abfuck langsam.
Oder liegt es am Raspberry Pi?
Ne, nicht wirklich.
Ich meine, mein Access Point ist einen Raum weiter, daran liegt es bestimmt nicht.
Ich meine, wir könnten, wir könnten, wir könnten mal einen IPerf oder so machen.
Ich mach mal kurz den Speedtest von dem Ding.
Okay.
Mal schauen kurz.
Kann ich jetzt nicht machen wegen IP-Leak.
Weil die Latenz hat ja nicht unbedingt was für die Übertragungsrate zu sagen.
Aber machen wir mal.
Die Luft ist heute zu langsam.
Ja, so sieht es aus.
Okay, also Geschwindigkeitsrekorde gewinnt das Tablet ja wirklich nicht.
Vielleicht ist auch der Amazon eigene ROM ein bisschen schneller.
Pressemeldung von Rockstar zu den Leaks.
Okay, Moment, das muss ich mir kurz angucken.
Was sagen sie?
Okay, zeigt mal kurz.
Okay, der Speedtest ist richtig langsam.
Keck.
44, 44 MB.
Äh, MBit.
Hahaha.
Das ist tatsächlich ziemlich langsam.
Da ist das andere aber schneller.
Weil ich bekomme keine On-, ich bekomme keine Tastatur hier drinnen.
Alter.
Ich muss mal kurz Chrome nachinstallieren.
Ich glaube hier ist irgendwas, hier ist irgendwas im Arsch.
So, also was schreiben die denn hier?
Zeigt mal her.
We recently suffered a network intrusion in, äh, äh, äh, ja, XS Development Footage at this time.
Okay, also typische nichtssagende Pressemeldung, oder?
Das ist ja, also okay, also die Pressemeldung ist ja komplett nichtssagend gewesen.
Jetzt hätte man sich auch sparen können.
Oder wisst ihr jetzt besser Bescheid, nachdem ihr das gesehen habt?
100 pro, he?
Jetzt ist natürlich alles klar.
Das ist ja wirklich absolut nichtssagende, äh, nichtssagende Presseerklärung.
Hätten die irgendwas zum Releasedatum oder irgendwas, irgendwas sinnvolles.
Aber so einfach nur, ja.
Aber zumindest, ich wollte es grad, ich wollte es grad sagen.
Zumindest weiß man jetzt, es war auf jeden Fall echt.
Das Leak.
Aber das war vorher auch deswegen, weil die Leute immer gesagt haben, das ist gefaked.
Das sah mir die ganze Zeit schon ziemlich legit aus.
So.
Ich hab mal kurz Chrome installiert, weil irgendwas mega lahm ist in diesem, in.
Onboard Browser.
Yes, install.
So, was wollte ich jetzt machen?
Sekunde.
Home Assistant starten.
Home Assistant starten habe ich gemacht.
Ah ah.
Ich wollte Firewall Freischaltung kurz machen.
Da ich euch was zeigen kann.
Ich muss das mal kurz einrichten.
So.
Also.
IP.
Firewall.
Add new.
So, Source.
192.163.
192.168.112.
Zu.
192.168.2.132.
Alles klar.
Except.
Okay.
Äh, meine Firewall Regeln sind broken.
Die funktionieren nicht.
Warum nicht?
Ach, jetzt.
Jetzt gehen sie, oder was?
Hä?
Oh, es gibt Sachen, die muss man nicht verstehen.
Na, 10 habe ich nicht.
Ich habe ein paar.
So, ist Chrome jetzt installiert?
Äh.
Chat, mein Tablet ist einfach aus.
Tablet, das Tablet hat sich gerade einfach resettet.
Ich glaube, das war.
Kann es sein, dass die Batterie leer war?
Ich sollte es, ich sollte es, glaube ich, mal wieder anschließen.
Es kann sein, dass die Batterie leer war.
Überhitzt.
Ne, Batterie ist angeblich noch 40 Prozent.
Hm.
Dann weiß ich auch nicht.
Aber, aber Leute, Chrome, Chrome geht.
Ah, Play Services sind not supported.
Jetzt geht's doch.
Chrome weiß nicht, Chrome weiß nicht, was es, was es will.
Erst sagt er, es ist nicht supported ohne Play Services und jetzt startet Chrome einfach so.
Na gut.
Also, ich muss sagen, das ROM ist schon ganz schön langsam.
Ich habe auf meinen anderen Tablets auch ein Custom ROM drauf, aber das ist schneller, kommt mir zumindest so vor.
Das ist aber ein bisschen ältere Android-Version.
Vielleicht ist die besser optimiert da drauf.
An den Speedtest kannst du komplett knicken.
Komplett.
Alter, ist das langsam, Mann.
Das kannst du komplett vergessen, Mann.
Das ist nicht benutzbar.
Nicht benutzbar langsam, ey.
Okay.
Vielleicht ist deswegen auch die Antwortzeit hier so lahm.
Gucken wir mal.
Ich guck mal kurz, ob ich meinen Home Assistant hier aufmachen kann.
Also, wenn das so langsam ist.
Also, wenn das so langsam ist, ganz im Ernst, dann bringt mir das nicht viel.
Wie geht denn hier mein Home Assistant auf?
Zeig mal kurz.
1, 3, 2, hier.
Gucken, ob der sich überhaupt bedienen lässt.
Punkt 2, Punkt, Doppelpunkt.
1, 2, 3.
Hä?
Nicht HTTPS.
Alter.
HTTPS, wo kommen wir denn da hin?
Okay, also das funktioniert schon mal.
Admin.
Aber das ist sehr, also die Bedienung, ohne Scheiß, Leute, die ist ultra laggy.
Weiß nicht, ob ich das so verwenden kann oder doch wieder die ältere ROM verwenden muss.
Das ist wirklich mega langsam.
Guckt mal, ich versuche euch das mal kurz zu zeigen.
Schaut mal.
Guckt mal, wenn ich hier rüber switche.
Warte mal.
Seht ihr?
So.
Seht ihr das?
Ich switch jetzt mal rüber.
Seht ihr, wie das laggt beim rüber switchen?
Und wie die Sachen nacheinander aufploppen?
Das kannst du, das kannst du mal komplett vergessen.
Also das ist nicht nutzbar.
Und sowas liegt bestimmt auch nicht an fehlenden Kugelservices oder sonst was.
Sondern es ist einfach lahm AF.
Welches Android das ist?
Ich denke 9?
Hätte ich jetzt mal vermutet.
Guckt mal.
About Tablet 9 ist das.
9.
Ne, ein iPad ist dafür unsinnig für das, was ich vorhabe.
Boah, das ist hyper laggy, der Browser.
Das ist auf dem anderen Tablet nicht der Fall.
Das ist auf jeden Fall nicht, nicht gut.
Was man, man sieht es ja irgendwie auch schon.
Das ist der neueste ROM, ja.
Man sieht es ja auch schon.
Guckt mal ernsthaft.
Wenn ich hier pinge und es liegt neben einem Access Point.
Alter, was ist das?
Mein anderes Tablet hat, ich, ich zeige, ich ping mal, ich ping mal kurz das andere Tablet
an.
Ähm.
DHCP Server.
Ich glaube wir müssen das andere wieder flashen.
Leases.
Fire.
12.
Hier.
14.
14 ist das andere.
Guckt mal.
Das ist das andere.
Äh.
Okay.
Das scheint ein etwas inkonsistentes WiFi zu haben.
Aber das andere läuft.
Aber das andere läuft um Längen besser.
Also auf dem anderen Tablet habe ich dieses ROM drauf hier.
Guckt mal.
Also das ist das, was wir jetzt hier gerade installiert haben.
Ich dachte mir, ich mache mal was Neueres.
Also auf dem anderen habe ich das da drauf.
Nichts.
Die, die, die, der, der ROM unterscheidet das.
Äh.
Gucken, wo das andere überhaupt ist.
Das da habe ich da glaube ich drauf auf dem anderen.
Ne.
14.
14.1 habe ich auf dem anderen drauf.
Und es läuft deutlich besser.
Also es ist auf jeden Fall viel, viel flüssiger.
Als damit.
Kann es daran liegen, dass ich keine Google-Services habe?
Eigentlich nicht.
Das ist doch vollkommen egal.
Ich meine ich habe ja sogar den Webview aktualisiert.
Das ist einfach lahm.
Ja.
Ich glaube, ich glaube das ist einfach.
Das ist zu neu für das Tablet.
Boah, der Speedtest ist so mega langsam.
Das kannst du gar, kannst du keinem zeigen.
Das ist unbenutzbar.
Die ganze Speedtest-Seite laggt.
Beim Speedtest machen.
Und er kommt auf 40 Mbit.
Ne, der ganze Browser ist langsam und laggy.
Gibt es irgendeinen coolen Browser-Benchmark?
Alter, das kannst du nicht verwenden.
Das ist komplett unbenutzbar.
Ich überlege gerade, ob ich noch das andere Flash jetzt.
Wie kriege ich denn da jetzt den anderen ROM drauf?
Ich bin mir gar nicht sicher, ob ich den ROM drauf habe oder sogar noch das 12.1.
Kann ich nicht einfach die downloaden jetzt und dann in das Boot-Menü gehen und die direkt flashen?
Also ich, ich downloade den Kram jetzt einfach vom, vom Tablet.
Und dann gehe ich in TWRP und, und flash das.
Das ist doch wahrscheinlich am einfachsten.
Dann mache ich das doch jetzt mal.
Mal gucken, wie, mal gucken.
Passt mal auf.
Passt mal auf, wie lahm der Download jetzt ist.
Du, du, du, du, du.
Äh, Download?
Alter, Android-Filehouse.
Was ist das für eine komische Seite?
Will ich da überhaupt irgendwas runterladen?
MonkaS.
Bin ich denn da?
Auf welcher Scam-Seite bin ich denn da jetzt?
Keine Ahnung.
Okay, hier. 14.
14.1 unofficial.
Es gibt nur einen 14.1, oder?
Click here to start download.
Ja, start.
Auf.
Gib ihm.
Du, du, du, du, du, du.
Oh, gut, dass ich nicht gezeigt habe.
Oh, ne.
Passt schon.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, gut, dass ich nicht gezeigt habe.
Ich dachte, es gibt TOS, TOS-Werbung, aber es war keine TOS-Werbung.
Es sah nur so aus.
Aber ich habe Schiss, dass es TOS-Werbung gibt.
Deswegen zeige ich es euch jetzt nicht.
So, download.
Download.
Was?
What?
File downloaded?
MonkaS, Alter.
Ah ja, okay, jetzt downloadet er.
11 Minuten, Mann.
Guckt mal, wie langsam mein WiFi ist.
Guckt euch das an.
11 Minuten.
Für 363 MB.
Und das wird mega heiß hinten.
Ach du Scheiße, Mann.
Okay, der ROM funktioniert.
Das ist gut.
Okay, der ROM funktioniert nicht richtig.
Das kannst du vergessen.
Ich glaube, ich, ich glaube ich.
Na, okay, ne, passt.
Der ist schon, der ist schon bei 40 MB, passt.
Ähm, jetzt mal eine andere Frage, Chat.
Wie komme ich denn jetzt überhaupt wieder in dieses Boot-Menü rein von eben?
Muss ich jetzt irgendwie Knöpfe gedrückt halten?
Ja, ich habe direkt, ich habe doch den direkten Vergleich.
Zwischen dem gleichen Tablet-Menü.
Zwischen dem gleichen Tablet mit einem anderen ROM und dem hier.
Rund, Volume Down und Power, also ich schalte aus.
Also ich fahre das Ding runter und dann drücke ich Volume Down und schalte ein, oder?
Ich glaube, im Reboot-Menü kann man einfach Recovery auswählen.
Okay, das probieren wir gleich aus.
Das probieren wir gleich aus.
Okay, wir haben schon, haben schon ein bisschen was.
Okay, das Download ist, das Download ist wirklich abfuck langsam.
Sekunde.
Sekunde, wir laden das, wir laden das jetzt nochmal hier runter.
Äh.
Ey, ich meine, Leute, guckt mal.
Der hier ist neuer.
Obwohl es, was ist denn das für ein Android?
Android-Version.
Was ist das für eine, wo sieht man das?
Steht das da dabei, was das für eine Android-Version ist?
5.
Ja, Android 5 ist, glaube ich, sogar sinnvoll.
Android 5 zu nehmen, wisst ihr warum?
Weil das Tablet wird ja eigentlich auch mit Android 5 ausgeliefert.
Das ist halt uralt.
Dann ne, ich glaube, ohne Scheiß, Leute, ich glaube, ich hab diesen, ich glaube, ich hab diesen ROM auf dem anderen drauf.
Das, das hau ich da jetzt, das hau ich jetzt einfach auch drauf.
So.
Ich hoffe, es kommt keine TOS-Werbung.
2000.
Ja, Download.
Was ist denn da das Neueste hier?
Das da.
Download.
Gib ihm.
Du, du, du, du.
Das ist fürs Fire HDC 2005.
Was?
Ne, ist es nicht.
Erzählt doch nichts, Chat.
Ey, wait a minute.
Ich glaube, das ist einfach nur Blödsinn, was da steht, oder?
Hä?
Ne, das ist, das ist Blödsinn, was da steht.
Ich glaube, das ist 2017.
Aber das hier ist es.
Aber das hier ist das Richtige.
Das ist das Richtige, was hier verlinkt ist.
Alter, jetzt flutscht's hier.
2017 ist das.
Okay, also Copy, Copy ROM to your device, Flash ROM.
Gut, dann rebooten wir jetzt mal, würde ich sagen.
Ich bin übrigens blöd, warum lade ich das denn hier runter?
Keg.
Copy Download Link.
Hier muss ich das runterladen.
Okay, dann, dann schließe ich das jetzt nämlich mal ans.
Abbrechen.
Dann schließen wir das nämlich jetzt mal wieder an Raspberry Pi an.
Und jetzt gucken wir mal.
Also, Chat, mal gucken, ob das funktioniert.
Rebooten?
Ne, geht nicht.
Also, nur mal, dass ich das jetzt richtig verstehe.
Ich mache jetzt Power Off.
Ich mache Power Off.
Und dann drücke ich Volume, was war's?
Volume Up oder Volume Down?
Du musst das erweiterte Reboot Menü.
Okay, wo, wo ist das?
Sekunde.
System Settings.
Erweitertes Reboot.
Pi Fat Time, was man hier alles.
Finde ich nichts zu.
In den Settings.
Wie heißt denn das?
Extended Reboot Menü.
Android.
Ja.
System, Gesten und Bewegung.
Mon KS.
System.
Advanced.
Gesten und Bewegung.
Nee, da steht nichts drin.
Wäre ja auch echt weirdchamp, oder?
Keine Ahnung, wo das ist.
Okay, ich schalte es jetzt aus.
So, Power Off.
Und jetzt?
Plus und Power Button halten.
Power plus Volume Down.
Okay, auf geht's.
Power und Volume Down.
Ja, geiler Amazon Knopf, Alter.
Was, was davon ist denn jetzt Volume Down und Up?
Da steht nichts drauf.
Ich denke einfach mal, das linke dürfte Volume Down sein.
Okay.
Jetzt ist das Logo erschienen.
Und jetzt?
War wahrscheinlich der falsche Knopf.
Ach so.
Woll...
Was?
Fastboot.
Nee, ich will Recovery, ne?
Volume Down plus Power ist richtig.
Nee, am Rand ist Volume Up.
Ernsthaft?
Ich probier das jetzt einfach aus.
Okay.
Okay, also Chat hier.
Das da?
Ich hab's rausgekriegt.
Das da ist Volume Up.
Und das da ist...
Also das linke ist Volume Down.
Power Off.
Okay, also ich will wahrscheinlich Recovery.
Also will ich Power Down plus...
Das hab ich gerade gehalten.
Okay, also.
Moment.
Ich will...
Ich will Power Down und Power.
So.
Ich hab das jetzt gedrückt.
Beides.
Massive.
Und nun?
Jetzt passiert gar nichts.
Auch gut.
Dann warten bis das Menü kommt bei Hold.
Da steht jetzt Amazon da.
Ich hold die jetzt weiter.
Nö.
Das klappt nicht.
Das bootet wieder.
Wisst ihr was ich jetzt mache?
Kann ich nicht einfach?
Kann ich nicht wieder ins Android Debug in ADB gehen und Step 1 ausführen?
So.
Wo hat das denn jetzt, wo hat das denn jetzt
downgeloadet? So, ich mach
jetzt, ich mach jetzt erstmal ADB an wieder.
Ich muss wieder ein
Developer werden. Hackermans-Heuch hier.
Bäm.
Ähm.
Wo sind denn die Developer-Settings jetzt?
Die
Developer-Options.
Da sind's doch. So.
Und jetzt ADB.
Android Debugging
aktivieren. Okay.
Alles klar.
Ja, ja. Gut.
Ja.
Also. Und jetzt ADB.
ADB
Reboot.
Recovery. So.
Oh, oh, oh.
Also wenn das jetzt klappt,
ist das ja mit Abstand das Einfachste. Da musst du dir nicht
merken, welche Knöpfe du für was drückst.
Ne, da ist wieder Amazon am Start.
Aha. Jetzt, jetzt erzählt
er da unten aber irgendwas von Recovery-Mode.
Aha.
Excellent.
Sehr schön.
So, wie ging das jetzt?
Sideload.
Sagt mir, wenn ich irgendwie komische Sachen mache.
Komische Sachen mache.
Sachen mache.
Keckel 2.zip.
Ja.
Erst Vibe, dann Flaschen.
Okay. Vibe.
Diesen Standard-Vibe
hier, Leute. Guckt mal.
Diesen Default-Vibe machen.
Einfach jetzt viben und gut ist.
Oder mehr.
Ja.
Swipe-Factory-Reset.
Der reicht. Alles klar.
Dann swipe ich jetzt mal.
Okay.
Halt.
Jetzt.
Ach, das war's.
Das geht aber ganz schön schnell.
So.
Und jetzt
Sideload.
Keckel 2.zip.
Bam.
Was?
Nee, was musste ich dazu machen?
Da musste ich erstmal Advanced Sideload
anklicken, ne?
Aha.
Wisst ihr? Ich lerne das, ja.
Okay.
Keckel 2 wird geflasht.
Ich hoffe jetzt, dass es nicht wieder
oder was heißt wieder? Dass es nicht
kaputt geht.
Guck mal. Allein schon das Flaschen geht
schneller als das letzte Mal.
Ja gut, das ROM wird ja auch kleiner sein.
Gucken wir mal.
Die ROMs sind ja wahrscheinlich einfach auch kleiner.
Das ist 5... Das ist...
Ja, guck mal. Das ist halt 100...
150 MB kleiner.
Hat hier schon wer eine Custom ROM gebaut?
Also ich nicht.
Habe ich auch ehrlich gesagt nicht vor.
Was schreiben die Leute
eigentlich in diesem anderen
Thread zu...
zu Performance?
Also wie gesagt, bei mir war das
mega langsam alles.
Oder muss man da noch mehr... mehr machen?
Overheating-Issue.
Na, ich will kein Overheating-Issue haben.
Da bin ich nicht so scharf drauf.
Ich will das Tablet an der Wand hängen lassen
und dann ist gut.
So, jetzt haben wir es geschafft.
Und jetzt...
Alter, weg.
Und jetzt ADB-Reboot.
So, ich zieh mal kurz hier ab.
Man weiß ja nie.
Jetzt sollte der starten.
Hoffe ich mal wieder.
Ganz normal.
Und jetzt den ROM halbwegs
bedienbar haben.
Beziehungsweise das OS halbwegs.
Guck mal hier, der Start geht auch schon viel schneller.
Ich hoffe.
Ah, jetzt muss ich wieder WLAN-Passwort eingeben.
Okay. Schauen wir mal.
Also das
müsste jetzt exakt das gleiche sein, was ich
auf den anderen Tablets auch drauf habe.
Eigentlich wollte ich heute mal das neuere ausprobieren.
Kannst du mal schauen, ob hier
WLAN per QR-Code einrichten geht.
Ja, ich zeig natürlich jetzt meinen
WLAN-QR-Code mal in die Kamera.
Android is starting.
Ich habe aber gar keinen QR-Code
zur Hand für meinen WLAN.
Dann müsste ich jetzt ein neues Gerät
Müsste ich jetzt ein neues Gerät
anlegen bei mir in den Settings.
So, jetzt machen wir erst mal WLAN gleich, wenn das gestartet ist.
Ist schon gestartet.
Ja, das ist gleich viel, viel
schneller.
Und er macht komischen Sound.
Ich hoffe, ich habe mich nicht vertippt.
Obtaining IP-Address. Nice, hat funktioniert.
Next.
Zeitzone.
Ja, Kokona.
Berlin.
Next.
Start.
Ja, got it.
Okay, Leute.
Wir sind back.
Und jetzt bin ich mal gespannt,
ob es jetzt besser funktioniert.
Ich will jetzt nicht die Kamera starten.
Lul.
Ich habe da keinen Browser drauf.
Kann das sein?
Standardmäßig.
Kann das sein, dass da standardmäßig kein Browser drauf ist?
Doch.
Was zum?
Alter, Leute, was ist denn das?
Moment.
Wartet mal.
Was zum?
Okay. Was ist?
Was ist das für ein Browser, Alter?
Startpage?
Was?
Privacy Mode?
Ich weiß gar nicht, was der von mir will.
Okay, jetzt.
Und ich bin verwirrt.
Wo ist mein Download überhaupt?
Ah, das APK ist noch da.
Okay, das ist gut.
Kann ich F-Droid gleich nochmal installieren?
Settings.
Startpage wurde als Google ohne Tracking gedacht.
Aber was ist das
für ein komischer Browser?
Total Default.
Kann ja sein.
Okay, jetzt muss
Odroid wieder 3 Stunden
3 Stunden refreshen.
Ne, nicht Odroid. F-Droid.
Odroid ist der Raspberry Pi Konkurrent.
Wie DuckDuckGo.
Ja.
Wobei DuckDuckGo ist ja immer noch gut, oder?
Oder ist
DuckDuckGo auch mittlerweile
China-Chinesen-Kram?
Oder wie ist das?
Ich hoffe nicht.
Und was ist China-Go
eigentlich?
Eigentlich ganz gern.
Ja, was mit Microsoft?
Okay, das ist mir neu.
Das nennt sich Privacy-Browser.
Aha.
Fliegt gleich weg.
So, ich hau den Aurora Store jetzt wieder drauf.
Und dann
update ich den Systemview.
Ja, Leute, ohne Scheiß.
Das ist so viel schneller, lässt sich das ganze schon bedienen.
Gerade.
es geht einfach next next next finish so webview webview aktualisieren webview aktualisieren und
richtigen browser installieren also schauen wir mal warum wir denn also viel league league
irgendwo hier wir brauchen den webview hoffe man erkennt irgendwas android system webview und dann
mein kiosk browser und in chrome mache ich auch mal drauf man weiß ja nie hoch was will er install
jawohl natürlich ich erlaube alles und liegt kommt man da heute hier irgendwas irgendwas sieht man
da von mir weiß ich weiß nicht genau was
man da von mir sieht aber aber irgendwas irgendwas sieht man da chromium ehrlich gesagt
will ich den chrome brauche ich in chrome gar nicht ich wollte jetzt eigentlich nur
mal installieren damit ich ein speedtest machen kann zum vergleich install und dann kommt eben
ein kiosk browser drauf wo ich dann mein homo system im fullscreen habe fullscreen habe und
fertig
mein kopf ach mein kopfhörer ist das hier mein mein mein mein head mein three head ist das
installing yes alles installieren next hinder pulli search das da install dann haben wir alles drauf mehr brauche ich nicht
dann haben wir alles drauf mehr brauche ich nicht
mit k.i. gesicht rekonstruiert pock lad das mal auf github hoch wie du das gemacht hast das wollen wir alle sehen glaube ich dann kann chainlaw irgendwelche emotes daraus bauen so ich mach mal kurz einen speedtest wir machen vorher noch mal eine andere sache wir pingen das ding jetzt nochmal ping warte mal das ist naja die dinge haben wir schon mal die dinge haben wir schon mal die dinge haben wir schon mal die dinge haben wir schon mal die dinge haben wir schon mal die dinge haben wir schon mal die dinge haben wir schon mal die dinge haben wir schon mal die dinge haben wir schon mal die dinge haben wir schon mal die dinge haben wir schon mal die dinge haben wir schon mal die dinge haben wir schon mal die dinge haben wir schon mal die dinge haben wir schon mal die dinge haben wir schon mal die dinge haben wir schon mal die dinge haben wir schon mal die dinge haben wir schon mal die dinge haben wir schon mal die dinge haben
sehr durchwachsen ist wähl hat aber scheiß drauf scheiß drauf erst mal die
ganzen sachen auf den startbildschirm kleben soll ich war mal schnell in
speedtest noch mal so zum vergleich jetzt es ist speedtest.net gel nicht
speedtest.org ja ich kann mir das immer nicht mehr
speedtest accept ja ist schon mal deutlich ich meine es ist immer noch
laggy as fuck ja aber die webseite funktioniert wenigstens halbwegs okay
es ist immer noch langsam aber es läuft besser
da bin ich da bin ich ja schon mal ganz froh darüber
ok nice da hätten wir das dann können wir jetzt eigentlich mit der home
assistant integration weitermachen beziehungsweise wir können das was ich
euch zeigen wollte weil ich habe jetzt auch ich habe jetzt alles drauf was ich
brauche mal jetzt home assistant nochmal schnell auf und zwar
doppel
punkt doppel slash was war das 192 punkt 168 punkt 2.132 doppelpunkt 8123
meine güte was man sich alles merken muss okay
kunst ja das ist viel schneller versteht zwar nicht so genau warum ich
meine neuere android version sollte jetzt ja eigentlich nicht so krass viel
langsamer sein
ja guckt jetzt ich kann euch mal im vergleich zeigen hier das gleiche was wir
vorher gemacht haben hier um switchen guckt der switch jetzt das wird jetzt
gleich habt ihr das gesehen sagt das ist das umgeschaltet
so jetzt können wir nämlich mal die neue integration ausprobieren die ist
wirklich nice man kann nämlich den kompletten das komplette tablet jetzt
fernsteuern damit überhaupt ist sind
natürlich nicht zu sehr gestartet statt wiritten wir mal eben mit dem
innen mit dem tollen
us Thursdays
integrations
ray
post 1 2 1 6 8 1
was war meine jetzt was ist die 14 oder die zwölf
monka es
hatten hier get a plus leistens naja ich will den demo modus ausprobieren remote administration
enable remote administration ob das muss man muss man machen remote passwort massive passwort 1234
kommt keiner drauf wie kommt kommen wir sind secure leute wir sind secure 1 2 3 4 5 6 ich
glaube jetzt kann nichts mehr passieren ich glaube jetzt haben wir es jetzt ist safe jetzt sind jetzt
sind wir safe activate alles aktivieren alles alles aktivieren alles aktivieren was warum
soll ich nochmal neu einloggen admin ach jetzt habe ich da ein watermark drüber oder was weil
ich plus features aktiviert habe ja das macht nichts ich habe ja sogar eine lizenz noch für
zwei für ein zweites für ein zusätzliches tablet mal kurz so platzieren das
man dank dem licht nix sieht so und jetzt kann ich hinzufügen 1 2 1 1 2 1 2 3 5 6 mit
du bist mich ein fünf spieljahren moin was war was verschreibt hallo max habe heute mit einem
nicht fett warum nicht
Egal. Nicht fett. Und die kennt
mich. Konnte damit ein, dass ich
meinen eigenen Emote auf deinem
Channel haben könnte.
Das ist doch Chebat, oder?
Das ist doch Chebat. Das glaube
ich dir nicht.
Das ist doch...
Das ist kein Chebat.
Nice.
Dann freut es mich, dass ich dir helfen konnte.
Indirekt.
Irgendwie konnte ich dir anscheinend
helfen. Wenn du sie noch
mehr beeindrucken willst,
kann ich
dir auch einen Clip aufnehmen, wo ich irgendwie
was sage.
Dann bist du...
Dann ist aber die Sache gesichert.
Okay.
Also, wo sind wir
jetzt stehen geblieben?
Ich will ja mal nicht so sein.
Okay, also guck mal. Wir konnten jetzt...
Es gibt
jetzt eine neue Integration für diese
App. Ich hoffe, man sieht das gescheit.
Eigentlich müsste ich es halt mal irgendwie
so hier hinlegen, aber dann
leuchtet es zu sehr. Aber passt mal
auf, was man jetzt machen kann.
Über Home Assistant, wenn man diese neue Integration
verwendet,
die weiß... Guck mal, man kann total
viel einstellen jetzt
auf diesem Tablet. Ich kann
Restart Browser machen zum Beispiel.
Bam. Restartet der Browser.
Habt ihr gesehen? Direkt
aus Home Assistant fernsteuern.
Ich kann sagen
Screen.
Was ist
das? Screen Brightness
kann ich sagen. Irgendwo.
Hier. Screen Brightness.
Oh. Jetzt ist es weg, weil der
Browser sich gerade neu gestartet hat.
Keck. Das ist natürlich super.
Das ist natürlich äußerst high IQ.
Den Browser... Ach, okay. Jetzt
rediscovert er das wieder. Alles klar.
Guck mal. Ich kann die
Screen Brightness einstellen.
Oh. Was?
Not a number.
Warum nicht?
Guckt. Seht ihr? Ich kann jetzt über
Home Assistant die Screen Brightness einstellen von
dem Gerät. Was ziemlich nice ist.
Ich glaube, das hier
ist... Das ist bugged. Guckt mal,
das ist bugged. Man kann
den Screensaver anmachen, was nichts
bringt, weil... Ich glaube,
ich hab gar keinen Screensaver da drauf.
Da geht einfach der Bildschirm aus, wenn
ich den Screensaver anmache. Screensaver
aus. Screen an. Screen
aus. Wenn du das echt
machen könntest, wäre das immer einfach
sagen, hallo, der Michael, voll nett und Grüße an
die Lisa. Ja, mach ich.
Hallo, der Michael, voll nett und Grüße an
die Lisa. Und jetzt
ganz wichtig. Weeps
in. Wenn's dir
hilft.
Passt doch.
Lol.
Stellt euch mal vor,
es bringt jetzt wirklich was.
Dann freue ich mich für ihn.
Gleich
die Überholspur genommen hier bei Lisa.
Wie's aussieht. Der Michael.
Warum?
Direkt erstes Kind da.
Genau.
Das jetzt flutscht.
Ah, Mann.
Ja, das wollte ich euch
zeigen. Das erste Kind muss
dann aber Max heißen, ja? Das ist aber
wirklich das Mindeste.
Wo bin ich jetzt stehen geblieben?
Keine Ahnung.
Aber das wollte ich euch zeigen.
Es ist doch wirklich nice, oder?
Dass man hier...
Man kann das übrigens sogar...
als Media-Player verwenden von Home Assistant aus.
Man kann da drauf dann irgendwelche Töne
abspielen und sowas.
Und der Chat kommt auf die Hochzeit.
Genau.
Seht ihr, aber es ist wirklich cool, oder?
Dass man das Tablet jetzt quasi komplett über Home Assistant
steuern kann. Und meine...
Also, was ich mit diesen Tablets
mache, ist folgendes.
Ich hab ein extra Dashboard, nur für Tablets.
So.
Und
dort
hab ich dann so Sachen,
wie, dass ich jetzt
Autoladestand, Fenster und
Türen geschlossen und sowas.
So die wichtigsten Sachen. Das hängt im Flur.
Und nachts,
wenn's Nacht wird,
mach ich dann zum Beispiel da drüber halt auch
über diese Fernsteuerung mach ich den Display dunkler.
Man könnte theoretisch den
Screen auch komplett abschalten.
Ja. Und man kann sogar
ULZ switchen da drüber.
Map leaked. OMG.
Map leaked, Leute.
Oh nein.
Man kann sogar die Startuhr
laden lassen. Guck, dann lädt er
die Seite neu.
Wo ich mir nicht ganz sicher bin, ist, ob ich
eine Custom-Uhr laden
kann. Was ist das hier?
Screen Saver Time.
Guck mal, du siehst
die...
den Batteriestand.
Du siehst die aktuelle
Seite. Und solche Sachen.
Ist wirklich nice. Ach ja, man kann
die Screen Orientation, glaube ich, auch
irgendwie umschalten.
Die Integration
gibt's erst
seit, glaube ich, dem letzten
oder vorletzten Home Assistant Update.
Also ist wirklich ziemlich neu. Und finde ich
aber in Kombination halt wirklich nice.
Cloudless Voice Assistant.
Gibt's ein paar Funktionen,
aber ich verwende keine Voice Assistant.
Deswegen kenne ich mich in dem Bereich nicht aus.
Die Preis ist für...
Also für die Hardware ist für den
Preis mehr als okay.
Du kaufst dir diese Dinger am besten,
wenn irgendein Amazon
Prime Day Weihnachtsspecial
oder sowas ist. Ich hab die damals, glaube ich,
für 80 oder 85 Euro
gekriegt. Normalerweise kosten die
unter 90 Euro. Normalerweise kosten die, glaube ich,
145. Was kostet
ein aktuelles Firehuggy?
150.
Ja. Mit und ohne Werbung.
Das ist Blödsinn. Ohne Werbung kannst du dir sparen.
Du musst halt mal gucken,
ob man die neueren Flaschen kann.
Wobei das nicht wirklich
notwendig ist.
Ich weiß nicht, ob man die neuen Flaschen kann. Die neuen sind von
wann? 2021, glaube ich, ne?
Ach, schauen wir mal.
Ja, die 2001...
Das hab ich auch. Das haben wir heute geflasht
und geroutet.
Suez. Suez hab ich auch.
Suez. Guck da.
Wobei ich den alten ROM genommen hab,
weil das neue nicht richtig
gelaufen ist.
Weiß gar nicht, ob die 2000...
Guck mal, die ganz neuen sind
anscheinend auch schon zu flashen.
Okay, dann ist eigentlich fast egal.
Kannst ja alles kaufen.
Anscheinend kann man das flashen, ja.
Das ist natürlich nice.
Ich muss mal kurz schauen,
ob man hiermit jetzt tatsächlich auch
die URL switchen kann auf dem Tablet.
Mal kurz gucken.
Also noch ist ja hier die Startseite.
Kann ich jetzt sowas machen,
wie hier Developer Tools, Services?
Huli?
Ne.
Äh.
Weiß gar nicht,
wie man das aufruft.
Anscheinend.
Anscheinend gibt's da keine.
Ne.
Anscheinend kann man da nicht die URL switchen.
Man kann nur zurück
switchen auf die Startseite.
Device plugged in battery.
Following controls are available.
Ne, gibt keine Services.
Load start URL kann man nur machen.
Also ich kann bloß sagen,
wo ist hier die
fully integration?
Ja.
Also ich kann bloß sagen,
load start URL.
Send to background.
Und dann?
Ah, dann bin ich im Hauptmenü.
Ne gut, das bringt mir jetzt nicht so allzu viel.
Bring to foreground.
Start URL.
Ist aber schon nice.
Tja, und jetzt muss man es halt so machen.
Also so werde ich es für dieses Tablet auch einrichten.
Und so habe ich es für die anderen Tablets auch eingerichtet.
Kann ich euch eigentlich zeigen.
Ich kann es euch zeigen.
Weil das ist wirklich ein echt cooles Feature.
Also ich habe folgendes eingestellt.
Ich habe mir einen extra Dashboard.
Nur für die Tablets.
Ein Dashboard mit so den wichtigsten Sachen.
Und ein Dashboard mit Kameras drauf.
Kameras kann ich euch jetzt natürlich nicht zeigen.
Außer ich baue mal eine Fake Kamera ein.
Könnt ihr eine Fake Kamera einbauen?
Dass ich es euch zeigen kann.
Zumindest habe ich es so gemacht.
Wenn es an der Tür klingelt,
dann switch ich es an.
Dann switcht das Tablet automatisch auf den Kamera-Tab für 30 Sekunden.
Aber instant switcht es um.
Und nach 30 Sekunden geht es wieder aufs Dashboard zurück.
So dass du quasi sofort gucken kannst.
Weil direkt daneben hängt die Tür gegen die Sprechanlage.
Wenn du dran gehst, kannst du direkt drauf gucken.
Wer ist das?
Sag ich, oh ne, das ist wieder der Typ, der uns Zeug verkaufen will.
Dann gehe ich gar nicht erst ran.
Das ist halt enorm praktisch.
Das geht alleine mit Fully allerdings nicht so schön.
Ich kann jetzt, ich kann hier einstellen, dass der,
also ich könnte als Startuhr die Seite mit den Kameras einstellen.
Und dann kann ich in den Settings einstellen,
dass der umschalten soll auf eine andere Seite nach so und so vielen Sekunden wieder.
Das ist aber nicht so schön, muss ich sagen.
Es ist auch langsam, weil er die Seite immer neu lädt.
Viel besser ist es, wenn man den Home Assistant selbst fernsteuern kann auf dem Tablet.
Und dazu gibt es ein eigenes Add-on.
Nennt sich Browser Mod.
Ich zeige es euch einfach.
Wir haben doch Zeit.
Gibt es den Home Assistant Browser Mod.
Und darauf kann man dann nicht nur den Browser fernsteuern mit Fully,
sondern komplett die gesamte Seite vom Inhalt her auf, also von, quasi klicken auf der Seite.
Ich muss aber erstmal den Home Assistant Community Store installieren, sonst wird das nichts.
Settings.
Integrations.
Haben wir hier Hux? Wo ist es denn?
Hux.
Haben wir nicht installiert. Muss ich noch installieren.
Mal kurz ein bisschen kleiner.
Dann zeige ich euch, wie das geht.
Ich brauche mal irgendeine Fake-Kamera.
Hat jemand irgendwie eine gute Webseite mit irgendwelchen Streams, wo man mal was einbinden kann?
Manhattan Webcam. Ja, perfekt.
Wenn die irgendwie eine gescheite...
Wenn die mal...
Die hat ja keinen RTSP-Stream oder so.
Kannst einfach die JPEG-URL rechts klicken.
Und dann updatet es öfters mal.
Ne.
Naja, müssen wir mal ausprobieren.
Erstmal muss ich den Home Assistant Community Store installieren.
Mach ich, mach ich.
Was? Generic Camera.
Gibt es irgendwo noch was anderes? Gibt es? Ok.
Camera.
MJPEG IP Cam.
Live-Kamera.
Ja, nee, nee, das geht so nicht.
Das...
YouTube geht, glaube ich, noch nicht.
Das wäre natürlich geil, oder?
Wenn du mittlerweile direkt YouTube-Streams in Home Assistant...
Nee, nee, YouTube-Streams gehen, glaube ich, nicht.
Es ist RTSP gedöhnt.
ATTP...
Ich meine, wisst ihr was? Ich probiere es einfach mal.
Streaming-URL. Mal gucken, ob das...
Ich glaube nicht, dass das funktionieren wird.
Mal gucken. Mal gucken.
Ne, sieht nicht so aus, als würde das funktionieren.
Welche Kameras kannst du empfehlen?
Ich habe auch zum größten Teil Reolinks.
Und, naja...
Für den Preis sind die unschlagbar.
Aber, sag mal so, nee, sondern nicht geil.
Hatte ich hier nicht letztens den RTSP-Test?
Admin-Q-Chat.
Nee.
Big-Bug-Bunny-Mov.
Genau, das brauchen wir.
Oh, das gibt es nicht mehr?
Och, shit.
Ja, aber das ging... Das habe ich doch gerade.
Probiert abzuspielen.
Ah, nice.
Sehr schön.
Dann nehmen wir doch das.
RTSP.
TCP-Transport.
Submit.
Created Configuration.
Nice. Da ist die Kamera.
Entity.
Zeig mal das Bild her.
Ob das jetzt funktioniert?
Mal kurz checken.
Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, wie man normale Kameras überhaupt einbindet in Home Assistant.
Ich mache das alles über RTSP.
RTSP-Stream.
Image?
Nee, wie geht denn das überhaupt?
Picture?
Oder einfach nur Entity?
Media?
Nee.
Camera?
Es war, glaube ich, Image.
Oder Picture?
Nee.
Meine Güte.
Schwer kann das doch nicht sein.
Picture?
Picture-Entity.
Die Clans-Card war das.
Das wird es gewesen sein.
Ja.
Nee.
Picture-Clans.
Genau.
Kamera.
Funktioniert ja exquisite gut.
Hey, es funktioniert.
Na ja.
Was ist denn der Unterschied zwischen Auto und Live?
Live.
Live funktioniert einfach.
Okay.
Nice.
Done.
Ich bin mir jetzt nicht sicher.
Das ist jetzt noch kein WebRTC, ne?
WebRTC ging ja nämlich nur mit dem Zusatz-Add-on.
Was ist denn das jetzt?
Network?
Ah, das ist HLS-Streaming.
Das ist HLS.
Okay, das ist auch HLS.
Auch okay.
Das läuft zumindest flüssig.
Also ich habe es mit dem WebRTC-Add-on.
Dann ist die Kamera quasi fast Echtzeit.
Und super, super schnell.
Aber das passt.
So, das können wir jetzt hier testweise nehmen.
Alles klar.
So, und jetzt zeige ich euch mal, wie ich das auf dem Tablet bei mir mache.
Also als erstes muss man ein neues Dashboard hinzufügen.
Ich kopiere mir mal die Kamera.
Das brauche ich.
So.
Also wir brauchen ein neues Dashboard.
Das ist ein bisschen versteckt.
Wir haben jetzt Add-Dashboard-Titel-Tablet.
View-Insidebar.
Ja, okay.
Können wir jetzt machen.
Icon-Tablet.
Placing the Fast.
Ne, das geht nur, wenn es written in Rust wäre.
Create.
Open.
Edit.
Empty Dashboard.
So, und jetzt habe ich hier zwei Sachen.
Ich habe Kamera.
Ein Kamera.
Und ein normales Dashboard.
So.
In dem Kamera-Dashboard habe ich dann ja quasi meinen ganzen Krempel hier drin.
Ich mache jetzt mal nur quasi exemplarisch eine Kamera rein.
Man kann auch hier zum Beispiel sagen,
man möchte das quasi immer im Fullscreen haben.
Oder was auch immer.
Das habe ich noch nie ausprobiert.
Ja, oder so.
In der Mitte.
Auf jeden Fall.
So.
Ja, oder so.
In der Mitte.
Auf dem Tablet ist so wahrscheinlich am besten.
Alles klar.
So.
Jetzt muss ich erstmal kurz gucken, wie ich auf die...
Hier.
Diese Url brauche ich jetzt.
Loveless-Tablet 0.
Und 1.
So kann man umschalten zwischen den Urls gleich.
So, hier machen wir jetzt irgendwie mal was anderes rein.
Irgendwie was so.
Wohnzimmer-TV.
So, und jetzt muss ich den gleich...
Jetzt muss ich dieses Dashboard einrichten auf dem Tablet.
Also hiermit starten wir.
Und so, dass ich es umschalten kann.
Also.
Dann gehen wir mal hier rein in die Settings.
Sagen wir hier.
Settings.
Start-Url.
So, und da wollen wir jetzt als Start-Url haben.
Muss mal abgucken.
Ich kopiere es mal auf die andere Seite.
Ah.
Loveless.
Slash.
Minus.
Tablet.
Slash.
1.
Okay.
Yes.
So, jetzt sind wir schon mal auf dem richtigen Dashboard.
Guckt.
Und jetzt will ich, dass sobald es klingelt bei mir an der Tür.
Hier drauf geswitcht wird.
Und dann nach 30 Sekunden wieder zurück.
Also.
Stellt euch vor.
Das ist die Kamera von der Tür jetzt.
Okay.
Also.
So sieht es von meiner Tür aus.
Standard Dashboard ist das hier.
Weil man das im Flur eben hängen hat.
So, dass es die wichtigsten Sachen anzeigt.
Wir können es ja auch mal ein bisschen.
Ja, hier.
Sehr gut. Das will ich jetzt alles haben.
Dann sieht das ein bisschen.
Dann sieht es ein bisschen gefüllter aus.
Okay, dann machen wir das.
Tablet.
Da ist so ein bisschen was los auf dem Dashboard.
So, Refresh.
Jetzt sieht es ein bisschen nach Dashboard aus hier.
Hand Leak.
O M F G.
Die Hand ist geleakt.
Keg.
Es gibt kein Keg Icon.
Das ist aber,
ist aber schwach.
Kein Keg Icon.
So, und jetzt muss ich erstmal den Home Assistant Community Store installieren.
Weil ansonsten kann ich nichts gescheites
machen.
Nichts gescheites.
Fax Install.
Keine weiteren Addons gescheiten ziehen.
Oder ja, doch geht.
Aber ganz im Ernst, das will man eigentlich nicht.
OS Supervised.
Go to the Addon Store.
Install SSH Addon.
Alles klar, machen wir.
Also, das muss man nur einmal machen.
Und das hat man normalerweise auch gemacht.
Weil, ich hab das SSH Addon drauf.
Weil niemand betreibt sein Home Assistant
ohne aktivierte,
ohne SSH Addon und ohne
Fax.
Das braucht man, weil darüber, werdet ihr gleich sehen,
kann man weitere Sachen nachinstallieren.
Ok, also 1, 3, 2.
Ne, was war das?
Root Add.
Oh.
Aber da, was hab ich denn da für ein
riesen Ding?
Gleich als Root drauf.
Bam. So, jetzt bin ich auf meinem Home Assistant
drauf und jetzt machen wir das hier.
Wir machen
Shell Befehle
als Root nach Bash Pipe. Also,
was soll da schon schief gehen bei?
So macht man das.
Ne, das ist nicht voll entzielt. Ich würd's dir aber empfehlen,
weil so kannst du viel einfacher Sachen nachinstallieren.
So.
Remember to restart Home Assistant
Home Assistant before
reconfiguring it.
Machen wir. Wir restarten Home Assistant.
Restart.
Restart Server. Bam.
Oh. Nicht Server.
Server Restarten
war nicht notwendig.
Er restart...
Hat er jetzt? Ne.
Ok, der G-Baiter, der
restartet gar nicht den Server.
Das war einfach
nur massivster G-Bait.
Der meint Restart Home Assistant.
Da steht Restart Server.
Die wissen selbst nicht, was wir da hinschreiben.
So.
Und jetzt muss ich
zu Integrationen gehen.
Add. Und da kann ich jetzt
Hacks hinzufügen.
Ja, ja.
Ist
alles klar?
Oh, fuck. Ich kann euch das nicht
zeigen. Ich muss ja GitHub-Authentifizierung
machen.
Das hab ich ja ganz vergessen, dass man
das machen muss.
Deswegen hab ich das hier auch nicht installiert.
Man muss ja
GitHub-Authentifizierung machen. Shit.
Ja,
ne, dann kann ich den Browser-Mod
so installieren.
So installieren?
Das muss man machen,
weil die Addons lädt da von
GitHub runter. Und GitHub mag das halt nicht,
wenn die Leute
auf ihrer Seite rumwursten. Und wenn du dir
halt quasi das authentifizieren lässt, dann
funktioniert's.
Installation Instructions.
So. Or copy contents
of custom components browser mode to your
custom components. Okay.
Machen wir. Alles
klar.
Ah ja.
Wo ist denn das? Config.
Ne.
Custom. Custom components.
Alles klar.
Okay. Git. Clone.
Dann machen wir's dahin.
So.
Und
jetzt sollen wir was hin kopieren? Den
unter custom mod
custom components
browser
mod. Hier hin.
Ja, hab ich gemacht. Okay.
Und jetzt muss ich wahrscheinlich rebooten.
Könnte ich mir vorstellen.
Rebooten.
Muss ich rebooten?
Restart Home Assistant. Ja.
Man muss ja mittlerweile alles restarten.
Deswegen hab ich übrigens auch
meine Fiat Integration für das Auto
als Addon gemacht.
Und bin ganz froh, dass ich's als Addon gemacht hab.
Weil Addons kann man wenigstens ordentlich neu starten.
Ohne alles 3000 mal neu laden zu müssen.
Gut. Integration mittlerweile auch.
Aber es funktioniert manchmal nicht.
Nun. Ich bin beeindruckt, wie schnell
der Home Assistant hier startet. Ehrlich gesagt.
Bei mir braucht das immer ewig.
Aber da ist ja auch viel mehr drin.
So. Jetzt haben wir den
Muss wir den Browser Mod da jetzt
noch hinzufügen? Browser Mod. Jawohl.
Browser Mod configured.
Gut. Ups.
Okay.
So. Und jetzt Trick 17.
Jetzt muss man
einmal das hier schließen.
Neu starten.
Und dann hat man in der Sidebar
Browser Mod.
Und dort
kann man dann hingehen und sagen
Register Device im Browser Mod.
Genau.
Danach muss man den ganzen Krempel nochmal abschießen.
Und nochmal starten.
Sonst funktioniert's nicht.
Und jetzt kann ich
den hier fernsteuern.
Den Browser. Von Home Assistant aus.
Guckt. Jetzt geh ich
ähm. Ne nicht auf Browser Mod.
Da wollt ich jetzt nicht hin.
Äh. Jetzt geh ich
auf
Developer Options
Services zum testen.
Und sag Browser Mod.
Navigate.
Und jetzt gehen wir
zu diesem. Jetzt sagen wir ihm, dass er auf
diese Seite umschalten soll. Hier.
Mit der Kamera.
Die aus irgendwelchen Gründen nicht geht.
Aber wahrscheinlich weil es abgekackt ist.
Ist egal. Ihr seht's gleich.
Navigate. Dahin.
Äh. Ich glaube ich muss nur so machen.
Choose Device. Diesen Browser.
Und jetzt pass auf.
Habt ihr gesehen? Er schaltet um.
Und das geht
saumäßig schnell.
Das heißt, ich kann mir das jetzt mal hier
copy-pasten. Und machen
eine Automation da draus.
Automations.
Automation.
Oh.
Empty Automation.
So. Actions. Also was wollen wir haben?
Wollen wir sagen Call Service.
Browser Mod. Navigate.
Dahin.
Und dann.
Nein das.
Ja. Ja und nein.
Das geht mit Fully Kiosk Browser auch.
Nur das Fully Kiosk Browser
immer einen kompletten Seiten Reload macht.
Was dazu führt, dass es alles
4-5 Sekunden länger dauert, als wenn du
die Seite direkt switchen lässt mit dem Browser Mod.
Aber die Kombination mit dem Kiosk
Browser ist trotzdem gut. Erstens
kannst du dich da nicht doof verklicken auf dem Tablet.
Und du kannst darüber Sachen
wie Bildschirmhelligkeit und so einstellen.
Also eigentlich in Kombination ist das
das Beste. So und jetzt muss man sagen
Wait. Also Stop für.
Ne nicht Stop.
Delete.
Actions.
Um das besser zeigen zu können. Ich gehe nochmal zurück.
Hier auf die andere Seite. Auf mein normales Dashboard.
Ich will jetzt eigentlich Wait.
Wait. Wait for Time Pass.
Sag mal hier irgendwie. Keine Ahnung.
15 Sekunden.
Und jetzt nächste Action.
Wieder auf.
Wieder Call Service.
Navigate.
Und jetzt gleich
das Tablet.
Und jetzt zurück auf das zweite.
Save.
Tablet
switchen.
Klingel.
Tablet.
Und jetzt kann ich
da drauf klicken. Also das wird jetzt getriggert.
Wenn ich.
Ich mach das mal groß. Also mir bräuchte
jetzt natürlich irgendwas wo man erkennt
dass die Haustür klingelt.
Geklingelt hat.
Und jetzt.
Dann triggert das das. So. Zack.
Dann switcht das um.
Zeigt euch das Bild.
Von der Haustür Klingel.
Und dann geht das automatisch hin.
Nach 15 Sekunden. Und navigiert zurück.
Wenn ich jetzt alles richtig gemacht hab.
So. Hat funktioniert.
Easy. Und man kann das dann ganz natürlich
auch schön kombinieren.
Wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel sagt. Ah ja gut.
Man kann das auch
ganz schön kombinieren.
Jetzt mit den anderen Sachen.
Zum Beispiel könnte man sagen. Ah ja ok.
Kann man das hier.
Kann man das hier irgendwie moven.
Ich mein ich kanns im jammeln moven.
Aber kann ichs hier irgendwie moven.
Move up oder so.
Ja und zum Beispiel.
Kann ich dann sagen. Danach.
Call Service.
Fully. Ne Quatsch.
Nicht Call Service.
Device ist es glaub ich.
Och ne.
Ja Amazon Fire.
Amazon Fire.
So und jetzt können wir ihm sagen.
Turn.
Turn off screen.
Also das ist jetzt nur ein Beispiel.
Ich wills ja standardmäßig anhaben.
Turn off screen.
Und jetzt
machen wir vorher noch was anderes.
Duplicate.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher.
Wie ich das gescheit verschieben kann.
Konnte man das nicht irgendwie moven.
Also im jammel.
Kanns auf jeden fall moven.
Weil ich will jetzt eigentlich sagen.
Turn screen on.
Ähm.
Ich weiß das man das irgendwie.
Moven konnte.
Ich glaub ich bin da zu pepega für.
Weil ich mein.
Man will das ja vielleicht auch mal bewegen.
Ich wollte jetzt.
Vor alles andere.
Dieses turn screen on machen.
Ok.
Home assistance.
Ich bin mir ziemlich sicher.
Dass ich das machen konnte.
Ach das war im letzten UI.
Das kann natürlich sein.
Aber kann ich jetzt das ganze vielleicht noch als jammel editieren.
Ok.
Ja dann ist es ok.
Dann kann ich es immer noch machen.
Turn on.
Genau.
So will ich das haben.
Ok.
Also.
Wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel sagt.
Nachts soll das Tablet aus sein.
Dann.
Habe ich das jetzt eingerichtet.
Jetzt sage ich run.
Dann geht das Tablet an.
Switcht auf die Kamera an der Tür.
Dann kannst du dir das angucken für 30 Sekunden.
Und dann switcht er automatisch wieder auf dein normales Dashboard.
Und macht das Tablet aus.
Da war auch reorder.
Ja das ist natürlich.
Für nachts ist das wirklich nice.
Wenn man nachts das Tablet aus machen will.
Alternativ.
Man kann das Tablet auch dimmen.
Ich hab das Tablet.
Nachts nur gedimmt.
Auf 1% oder so.
Ja und wenn es jetzt wieder klingelt.
Geht es an.
Switcht rüber auf die Kamera.
Und geht.
Das ist wirklich nice.
Man konnte hier oben reordern.
Ach.
Jetzt sind da.
Ok ich verstehe.
Normale Pfeile waren anscheinend zu bloated.
Ich meine.
Äh.
Du hast offensichtlich keinen Platz mehr.
Für so einen Drag und Drop Button.
Kannst du auch erst switchen.
Und dann einschalten.
Du meinst das ich zuerst switche.
Das geht auch klar.
Kann ich auch machen.
Du meinst das man nur das eine sieht dann.
Das ist gleich.
Das man das umschalten gar nicht sieht.
Ja ja das funktioniert auch.
Kann auch das hier zuerst hin machen.
Ja.
Browser Mod.
Nee nee das funktioniert nicht nur bei eingeschaltetem Display.
Guck.
Run.
Du hast es jetzt noch kurz gesehen.
Du müsstest vielleicht noch ein Delay einbauen.
Wenn du wirklich nicht willst das es das sieht.
Nee nee das funktioniert auch bei ausgeschaltetem Display.
Ja.
Und ich habe es halt so.
Ich habe nicht.
Ähm.
Hier Screen on.
Sondern ich habe hier drinnen.
Auf.
Und hier nachts ist.
Brightness.
Kann man hier nämlich auch einstellen.
Man kann sagen.
Set Value Brightness auf 1.
Oder gar auf 0 kann man sogar sagen.
Save.
Und wenn ich das jetzt ausführe.
Guck dann.
Geht an.
Switch drüber auf die Kamera.
Und nach 15 Sekunden.
Display das Tablet bleibt die ganze Zeit an.
Ja wenn das einstellt.
Du kannst die Displaysperre auch ausmachen.
Guck.
So habe ich es nachts eingestellt.
Das finde ich viel besser.
Ich will das gar nicht komplett aus haben.
Ich will es einfach gedimmt haben nachts.
Und so finde ich das.
So finde ich das nice.
So kann man das lassen.
Zack zack geklingelt.
Und ihr seht jetzt auch.
Wie schnell das geht mit dem umschalten.
So ich mach mal wieder.
Volle Pulle die Helligkeit.
Sehr nice.
Excellent.
So habe ich es eingestellt.
Das ist eines der Gründe.
Wofür ich die Tablets verwenden will.
Einfach das man sieht.
Wenn es klingelt an der Tür.
Wer da vorsteht.
Und das ich die wichtigsten Sachen auf einen Blick habe.
Nämlich.
Also bei mir.
Ich kann euch mein Dashboard ja mal zeigen.
Mein richtig echtes Dashboard fürs Tablet.
Ich muss mal kurz gucken ob ich da nicht irgendwas drauf habe.
Was man nicht sehen sollte.
Ne.
Ne kann ich euch doch nicht Screenshotten.
Kackel.
Ne geht nicht.
Jetzt hätte ich fast geleakt.
Wobei doch.
Ich leake euch das mit.
Ich mach einfach einen Kasten drüber.
Dann seht ihr nichts.
Also so sieht mein Dashboard aktuell aus.
Was ich auf dem Tablet habe.
Das ist wirklich nur das wichtigste.
Und ganz minimal.
Was man halt braucht.
Wie gesagt die Tablets sind jetzt auch nicht so fett.
Deswegen.
Das Tablet ist ja schon zur Hälfte voll damit.
Ich sehe wie voll das Auto ist.
Ob Fenster und Türen auf oder zu sind.
Und aktuell Uhrzeit und Wetter.
Und hier ist der Knopf für die Kameras.
Von der Eingangstür.
Vom Hof und der Eingangstür.
Mehr brauche ich auf dem Tablet nicht.
Ich lasse mir lieber noch ein bisschen Platz.
Dass ich was hinbauen kann.
Falls ich es brauche.
So sieht es aus.
Jetzt haben wir es eingerichtet.
Das funktioniert auch relativ.
Zackig.
Hier auf dem Tablet.
Also das Video.
Ah meine Güte ich kann ja tippen.
Automations.
Guckt.
Na super.
Jetzt ist das Video gerade fertig.
Perfekt.
In dem Moment wo ich umgeschaltet habe ist das Video fertig.
Jetzt müssen wir warten bis das Video gestartet wurde.
Der Film ist gerade fertig.
Sehr gut.
Kann man sehr schön demonstrieren.
Das geht halt nur weil es I3 ist.
I3 ist halt äußerst
POG was das angeht.
Ich habe die Tablets dauerhaft am Strom.
Ja.
Naja ist jetzt ja nicht so als würde das wahnsinnig viel verbrauchen.
Wo hast du jetzt den Screenshot
von deinem Port Home Assistant gemacht?
Auf dem zweiten Desktop.
Auf dem zweiten Rechner hier neben.
Da wo ich auch die Bilder durchklicke.
Ah ja jetzt geht es wieder.
Millionär.
Das schöne daran ist.
Ich will kein Millionär sein um sowas selbst bauen zu können.
Guckt es läuft auch alles flüssig.
Und hat überhaupt keine Probleme.
Und ich habe 1080p.
Kamera Streams.
Zwei Stück.
Also das Tablet hat schon ein bisschen was zu tun.
Deswegen habe ich es lange Zeit auch
probiert und Probleme gehabt.
Weil es ging lange kein WebRTC da drauf.
Auf den Amazon Dingern.
Außer mit dem offiziellen Stock ROM.
Deswegen hatte ich auf dem hier halt noch das Stock ROM drauf.
Aber jetzt.
Jetzt ist gut.
Jetzt funktioniert das auch so.
Ja soll ich euch noch irgendwas zeigen?
Ich glaube.
Nämlich das war es so im Großen und Ganzen.
Wir haben Flashchamp gemacht.
Wir haben Home Assistant eingerichtet.
Man sieht das hier mit dem Browser Mod.
Wie nice das funktioniert.
Hast du Sprachsteuerung?
Ne Sprachsteuerung mag ich nicht.
Ich habe lieber noch ein weiteres Dashboard als Sprachsteuerung.
Keine Ahnung.
Mein neues Auto hat ja auch Sprachsteuerung.
Standardmäßig.
Da kannst du dann sagen.
Hey Fiat mir ist kalt und sowas in der Richtung.
Verwende ich auch nicht.
Ich drücke einfach den Knopf.
Du brauchst genau einen Knopf.
Um die Heizung oder die Klimaanlage
einzuschalten.
Ich wüsste nicht warum ich das über Sprachsteuerung machen sollte.
Und wenn es gerade super Intens ist.
Auf der Straße.
Dann drücke ich halt 10 Sekunden später.
Black HD das ist keine schlechte Idee.
Das kann man machen.
Ich glaube sogar die Elgato Sachen.
Haben eine ganz gute Home Assistant Integration.
Guck mal mal.
Stream Deck.
Home Assistant.
Ah da gibt es Custom Plugins.
Weil.
Weil die Lichter von Elgato.
Die haben eine offizielle Home Assistant Integration.
Habe ich euch ja schon gezeigt.
Also mein.
Hier dieses Elgato Ring Light was ihr hier gerade seht.
Das habe ich ja auch bei mir im Home Assistant drin.
Und dann kann ich.
Ich mache es mal kurz auf.
So.
Das kann ich.
Hier drüber an und ausschalten.
Und auch im Zweifelsfall die.
Helligkeit.
Und so Zeug umstellen.
Auch Farbtemperatur und sowas.
Hast du was mit dem selbst gehausten Sprachsteuerung gemacht?
Nein.
Ich habe mal ein bisschen rumprobiert.
Mit.
Was war das denn nochmal.
Irgendein Projekt von Github.
Was dann aber von der Hand her.
Die Handhabung viel zu.
Kompliziert war.
Da hast du Raspberry Pi's im Haus verteilen müssen.
Mit Mikrofon und so.
Ich hätte es.
Ich würde ja die Sprachsteuerung vielleicht.
Manchmal verwenden von meinem Home Assistant.
Wenn ich es einfach über die App.
Wenn ich einfach auf Mikrofon drücken könnte.
Und dann über die App.
Also aktuell.
Ich habe wirklich keinen Anwendungszweck.
Großartig für Sprachsteuerung.
Control your Home Assistant Devices vom Stream Deck.
Ja.
Wenn ihr euren Fiat.
Wenn ihr euren Fiat auch von Home Assistant.
Controllen wollt.
Könnt ihr mal ein Addon ausprobieren.
Wobei Commands noch nicht funktionieren.
Das muss ich.
Das muss ich echt die Tage mal einbauen.
Aktuell kann man ja so Sachen nur abrufen.
Agila Champ.
Der ist zu alt.
Der kann sowas nicht.
Aber halbwegs neue Fiat's können das alle.
Ja.
Ich schaue mal in den Chat.
Ansonsten glaube ich war es das.
Mir fällt da sonst gerade nichts ein.
Kannst du dir vorstellen.
Ja klar.
Mache ich gerne.
Zeige ich.
Also wenn ihr wollt.
Wir können ruhig ab und zu mal.
Zeigt mir dein Home Assistant Dashboard machen.
Das fände ich sogar sehr spannend.
Ehrlich gesagt.
Also wenn gerade einer was hat.
Was er teilen möchte.
Irgendwo hochladen auf irgendeinem Imagehoster.
Und posten.
Können wir uns jetzt auch noch ein paar Dashboards angucken.
Würde mich sogar echt interessieren.
Weil ich immer spannend finde was andere Leute machen.
Und man bekommt viel Inspiration.
Da drüber.
Oder auf Discord.
Das ist eine gute Idee.
Wir haben doch ein Heimautomatisierungs Channel.
Auf Discord.
Oder über Twitter.
Eigentlich ist mir das egal.
Aber wenn wir es jetzt im Stream machen wollen.
Dann ist es gut wenn man es jetzt postet.
Aber für die Zukunft.
Wir könnten das tatsächlich mal sammeln.
Und uns ab und zu ein paar Home Assistant Dashboards angucken.
Ja tatsächlich.
Also BlackHD.
Wenn du dein Dashboard sharen willst.
Hau es auf Immigur oder sonstigem Zeug hoch.
Und wir können uns angucken.
Ich gebe meinen Senf dazu.
Kannst auch ein Screenshot vom Tablet.
Oder vom Handy machen.
Ja.
Das ist eine gute Inspiration da durch.
Wenn man sich das anguckt was andere machen.
Hast du eigentlich auch Geräte die kein WPA3 können?
Ich glaube.
Ich habe gar keine Geräte die WPA3 können.
Können.
Also das Ding kann auch im Leben kein WPA3.
Also ich habe glaube ich.
Ich weiß nicht.
Ob ich ein Gerät habe was überhaupt WPA3 Support hat.
Ja doch.
Das iPhone hat wahrscheinlich WPA3 Support.
Ach so.
Ja so habe ich das auch eingestellt.
Also.
Das ist glaube ich auch Default.
Auf meinem Access Point gewesen.
Irgendwie 3 plus 2 oder so.
Ja.
Ich habe da nichts rum.
Ich habe mich damit noch nicht beschäftigt ehrlich gesagt.
Ist alles Default gelassen.
Jo.
Und Chat gibt es noch was?
Ansonsten gehe ich jetzt.
Ah ne ich gehe noch nichts essen.
Aber bald.
Also wie es mit meinem Staubsauger Roboter aussieht.
Weiß ich gar nicht.
Den habe ich.
Übrigens nicht mehr.
Also ich habe euch ja schon ein paar mal gezeigt.
War ich hier im Stream per SSH auf meinem Staubsauger eingeloggt.
Aber den benutze ich nicht mehr.
Ich benutze aktuell keinen Staubsauger Roboter mehr.
Ich fand die Dinge an sich am Anfang wirklich.
Sehr nice.
Und habe mir auch eingerätet.
Das bringt richtig was.
So nach dem Motto losfahren und sonst was.
Aber ich habe halt auch noch einen.
Ohne selbst reinigende Station.
Es gibt ja mittlerweile schon richtig coole Geräte.
Mit Station und sowas.
Mit selbst reinigenden Stationen und sowas.
Vielleicht würde ich damit das ganze verwenden.
Aber es ist halt so.
Der Staubsauger Roboter.
Den kannst du halt einstellen.
Ich stelle es dir ein, dass der um 10 Uhr losfährt.
Oder wenn du Homeoffice startest, der losfährt.
Das ist okay.
Aber du musst den Scheiß ja trotzdem rausräumen.
Und.
Ehrlich gesagt.
Du musst dich dann bücken.
Du musst das Ding auf den Tisch stellen.
Du musst das Fach rausklipsen.
Dann musst du zum Mülleimer laufen.
Das Fach reinleeren.
Dann musst du es wieder reinmachen.
Und wieder auf die Ladestation stellen.
Ganz im Ernst.
Und das machst du dann alle zwei Reinigungsparten.
Oder alle zwei bis drei Reinigungsparten.
Oder drei Reinigungsparten.
Oder vier.
Oder zwei Tage.
Oder was auch immer.
Das ist nervig.
Ganz ehrlich.
Ich nehme lieber einen normalen Staubsauger.
Der hält der Beutel ewig gefühlt dagegen.
Dann fahre ich alle eineinhalb Wochen durch.
Das Ding saugt besser.
Das saugt stärker.
Das kannst du viel schneller fahren.
Das ist ja bestimmt 40 Minuten.
Bis der komplett fertig war.
Ich bin in zehn Minuten durch.
Wenn überhaupt.
Wenn es so lange dauert.
Ich bin wieder bei einem normalen Staubsauger angelangt.
Finger Leak.
Da bin ich nicht scharf drauf.
Ich habe den Staubsauger noch.
Aber da steht er im Wohnzimmer rum.
halt im wohnzimmer rum und macht nichts ok ja mit der aus mit der automatischen entleerung station
das ist zum ersten mal wo ich sage ja das klingt mir sinnvoll und da würde ich mir vielleicht auch
ein wieder hinstellen ist halt die sache ich bräuchte halt ein ohne china chinesen cloud
weil ich habe echt keinen bock dass mein staubsauger roboter nur mit cloud richtig
funktioniert ich habe auch keinen bock auf staubsaugen meine katz hat zum glück nicht
so viel bisschen saugen schimmel ok zeit war ja gucken wir jetzt sehen wir mal schauen wir
noch mal was an also ich habe echt immer gedacht dass für mich so ein staubsauger
roboter niemals in frage kommen weil ich ja bei mir ist es umgedreht ich hatte ein und ich finde
normales saugen ist besser ziemlich unordentlich bin und bei mir immer manch eine vr brille ja ok
also so sieht's mal aus
und die dinger damit ja offenbar nicht klarkommen außerdem habe ich in meiner wohnung vor allem
hartböden da will ich lieber wischen als saugen beide probleme sind längst gelöst sagt zumindest
meine hat auch eine wischfunktion aber ich habe die noch nie verwendet staubsauger roboter
expertenkollege stefan deshalb hat er mir das ct redaktionsleihgerät roborock s7 max v ultra für
ein halbes jahr ausgeliehen
ja das ist der mit der station oder der hat leider sensoren
also raummessungen per laser eine rgb kamera kann wischen und das ist der dass der s7 das ist er das
mit station jetzt kommt das beste den ganzen dreck ja den ich aus dem roboter rausholen er reinigt
sich also selbst mit seiner saugstation ja das ist cool ohne scheiß ich glaube mit so einer station
da könnte ich mich auch wieder damit anfreunden ich bin ausprobiert und das war wirklich toll das war so, das ist so so mit dem...
ja das ist cool und richtig das klingt richtig ...
...
echten Härtetest. Vorab eine kleine Inhaltswarnung, es wird ein paar ziemlich eklige Bilder mit Dreck
und Gammel und so geben. Bleibt dran. Liebe Hackerin, liebe Internetsurfer, liebe Hackerin,
liebe Internetsurfer, herzlich willkommen hier bei... Dieses Video wird gesponsert von
Sophos und von Sophos kommt auch diese Botschaft. Cyberkriminelle nehmen nicht nur... So erstmal
ganz kurz vorab, dass ich mich bei diesem Langzeittest für den Roborock S7 Maxx V Ultra
entschieden habe. Das war eine ziemliche Zufallsentscheidung. Das war ein Roborock...
Was heißt entschieden? Ich denke, er hat einfach einen gekriegt als Leihgabe.
...Leihweise zur Verfügung gestellt. Testgerät war gerade in der CT-Redaktion und wurde dort
nicht benötigt. Da habe ich mir das mal für eine Zeit mit nach Hause genommen. Außerdem fand ich
die Funktionen alle ziemlich interessant. Vor allem die Wischfunktion... Das Ding braucht doch
aber China-Chinesen-Cloud, oder? Ich habe keinen Bock auf Cloud-Only-Staubsauger-Roboter.
...Bescheinigung...
Und die Lasermessung. Ich hatte vorher noch nie so einen Roboter in der Hand und trotzdem lief die
Ersteinrichtung absolut problemlos. Der Roboter selbst ist in diesem kleinen Karton. Da drin ist
auch die einfache mitgelieferte Ladestation. Da fährt er automatisch rein nach ein bisschen
rumgerödelt. Hat meiner auch gemacht. Aber ich habe hier ja die Ul... Und ich hatte es halt...
Guck mal, bei mir stand das auch im Wohnzimmer an der Wand. Und du musstest immer das Ding hochheben,
auf den Tisch stellen, umdrehen. Das Behält...
Behälter rausmachen, Behälter ausleeren, Behälter wieder reinmachen, wieder auf die Ladestation
stellen. Das ging mir einfach auf den Sack. So, und ich... Ich weiß nicht. Vielleicht,
vielleicht würde ich das auch verwenden mit Entladestation. ILO, danke für den Sub.
Aber ich habe hier ja die Ultra-Version und deshalb noch einen zweiten, viel größeren Karton. Da drin
ist die riesige Absaug- Boah, das ist aber ein Ding.
Da gibt es drei Behälter. Hier rechts ist der Staubsaugerbeutel drin, in der Mitte das frische
Wasser und hier links das dreckige. Ganz schön, ganz schön, also okay. Das könnte ich dann
beispielsweise gar nicht mehr ins Wohnzimmer gescheit stellen. Damit soll es möglich sein,
dass der Roboter mehrere Wochen lang autark unterwegs ist, ohne dass man da irgendwas
ausleeren oder reinigen muss. Der von mir getesteten S7 Max V Ultra-Variante mit der
Station kostet... Guckt euch mal den Namen von dem Ding an. Roborock S7 Max V Ultra-Staubsaugerroboter.
1.400 Euro. Boah.
Der Sauger selbst kostet rund 700 Euro. Ja, habt ihr richtig gehört, die Station kostet genauso
viel wie der Sauger selbst. Und das finde ich auch seltsam, ja. Aber wir können uns ja erst
mal anschauen, wie Sauger und Station überhaupt funktionieren. Also hier oben in der Mitte des
Roboter ist der LiDAR-Turm. Damit orientiert er sich. Und seitlich sind eingebaut LED-Aufhelllicht,
RGB-Kamera und dann noch so mechanische Sensoren, weil der echt mal... Wisst ihr, ich meine, ja,
wenn ein Roboter... Ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja.
Wenn einer sagt Verschwörungstheorien so, ist er vielleicht nicht ganz, ganz falsch. Aber ich will
keinen China-Cloud-Roboter mit Kameras bei mir in der Wohnung haben. Ich kann mich mit diesem
Gedanken einfach... Also erstens ein Staubsaugerroboter, der Cloud-mäßig funktioniert. Okay, das ist das
Erste, was ich nicht will. Und dann einen mit Kameras will ich noch weniger. Und ich will eigentlich
auch nicht die offizielle App dafür verwenden, sondern ich will das ordentlich integrieren. Gut,
Home Assistant-Integration gibt es, glaube ich, mittlerweile über die API ganz gut. Aber immer
noch halt über die Cloud. Und ich verstehe es halt einfach nicht. Warum muss mein Staubsauger-Roboter
nach China, übers Internet nach China, damit er funktioniert? Mal irgendwo gegenstößt. Das hier
ist die Hauptbürste. Das ist die Seitenbürste, mit der er Dreck von den Zimmerrändern in die
Hauptbürste rein manövriert. Und wenn man die Brille auf die Brille schließt, dann hat er auch
einen Dreck. Und wenn man die Bürste rausnimmt, sieht man das Einsaugloch. Die Saugkraft, also genau
genommen die Druckdifferenz, liegt laut Oberrock bei 5100 Pascal. Zum Vergleich, bei normalen
Bodenstaubsaugern mit Kabel geben die Hersteller mindestens das Doppelte an, wenn nicht sogar das
Dreifache oder Vierfache. Das merkt man auch. Ich habe es jetzt ja direkt probiert. Ich habe die
ganze Zeit auch oben diesen Staubsauger-Roboter rumfahren gehabt. Und jetzt sauge ich wieder mit
einem ganz normalen Staubsauger. Und es flutscht einfach nicht. Das ist ja auch ein bisschen
einfach. Vielmehr. Hier ist das Wischtuch. Das nennt sich offiziell Vibra Rise Mob-Tuch. Also
Vibra wohl wegen der Vibration. Das Tuch wird nämlich ganz schnell mit Ultraschall hin und
her bewegt. Ganz schön am Schwitzen. Weil es automatisch hochgezogen werden kann. Na gut,
es war ja im Sommer das Video. Die Absaugstation, also seine Roboter-Hundehütte, funktioniert so.
Wenn der Roboter vom Reinigen zurückkommt, wird das Wischtuch mit Wasser aus dem Frischwasser-Berlter
und ganz zum Schluss wird es dann noch mal richtig laut. Dann saugt nämlich die Station den Staub aus
dem Sauger in diesen Staubbeutel in der Station. Der hält erstaunlich lange. Im Test waren es
dreieinhalb Monate lang. Bei mindestens drei Reinigungsdurchläufen pro Woche. Vielleicht
habt ihr jetzt schon in einem anderen Tab geguckt, wo es das Teil gibt und seid jetzt verwirrt,
weil ihr da eine Pro-Version gefunden habt, die sogar preisgünstiger ist. Nämlich mit Absaug-
und Wasserstation nur 1.100. Stattdessen ist das eigentlich okay. Das ist eigentlich okay.
1.400 Euro. Ja, habt ihr recht, der ist neuer. Der hat aber leider auch weniger Funktionen. Von der
ganzen Putzerei ist der S7 Pro Ultra identisch. Er hat... Oh Mann! Warum schafft es kein Hersteller,
mal irgendwie ein sinnvolles Produktbenahmungszeug durchzuführen? Aber keine Kamera zur Orientierung,
nur den Lasersensor. Was euch dadurch... Das wäre mir wahrscheinlich lieber. Ihr könnt nämlich in
der Roborock-App quasi durch die Augen des Max V Ultra... Okay, das ist natürlich schon cool.
Das sieht schon ziemlich cool aus, oder? Und ist auch ganz schön gruselig. Das ganze klappt übrigens
auch, wenn man gar nicht im selben WLAN ist. Man kann das halt also theoretisch... Ja, und der
China-Chinese guckt dann bei dir zu in der Wohnung. ...aus 5.000 Kilometer Entfernung saugen und wischen
lassen und es als fahrbare Überwachungskamera nutzen. Es gibt sogar einen manuellen Modus,
wie so ein ferngesteuertes Auto und damit kann man sogar Durchsagen machen. Tolle Funktion.
Achtung, Achtung! Das bräuchte... Da könnte ich meine Katze verwirren, wenn ich nicht da bin,
und ich rede auf einmal. Auch ein Mikrofon eingebaut, also der Roboter überträgt auch das,
was als Antwort... Ach, dann kann man mit den Leuten sogar sprechen. Man kann quasi telefonieren über,
reden über den Schaubsaugerroboter. ... im Raum dann gesprochen wird. Also ziemlich
futuristisch und man kann damit ganz gut Leute erschrecken. Diese Videofunktion ist
nicht standardmäßig eingeschaltet. Das muss man manuell aktivieren. Und wenn ihr Angst habt,
dass Roborock euch ausspioniert, das Gerät funktioniert auch ohne jeden
Internetverbindung. Zumindest im Standardmodus. Wenn man den Knopf hier drückt, säubert es die
ganze Wohnung und fährt auch automatisch wieder ins Dock zurück. Aber mehr halt nicht. Wenn ihr den
S7... Ja, das ist natürlich doof. ... der App verkoppelt, kann man sehr viele Sachen mehr
machen. Zum Beispiel die Saugleistung in 4 und die Wischintensität in 3 Stufen einstellen. Ihr
könnt No-Go-Zonen einrichten, genau festlegen, in welcher Reihenfolge er die Zimmer abklappern
soll, dass an bestimmten Stellen nur gesaugt und an anderen nur gewischt wird und so weiter und so
weiter. So, aber jetzt wirklich mal zu meinen Erfahrungen. Ich war am Anfang definitiv positiv
überrascht, dass das Ding doch einigermaßen mit meiner Wohnung klarkommt, wo nicht jeder Zentimeter
freigeräumt ist. Also Stühle, Kissen und sowas sind kein Problem. Bisschen Spielzeug ist auch
nicht schlimm. Das schiebt der Roboter aber womöglich etwas durch. Mal gerade was gucken.
Ups, jetzt habe ich irgendwie... äh... wo... 7... 7,48 waren wir, gell? Wo hier? Ähm, ich wollte mal
gerade was gucken. Github? Auf welchen Geräten...
läuft denn das aktuell? Gibt da irgendwas? Supported Devices? Supported Robots! Roborock.
Nope. Die gibt es nicht mehr. Die werden nicht mehr supported. Die neueren. Die haben wahrscheinlich
einfach keine Sicherheitslücken mehr, dass Du so flashen kannst. Ja, sind zu wenig. Ist im Prinzip
nur die Dreamy Dinger und die älteren Roborocks. Aber ich will halt ein. Warum baut denn keiner?
mal einen Staubsauger-Roboter
mit Absaugstation,
was gut funktioniert, aber
lokal
steuerbar über sinnvolle
APIs, ja, sei es ein Web-Interface,
sei es MQTT, sei es
irgendwelche Rest-Endpoints, was auch immer.
Warum muss es immer nur
diese eine App sein und China
Chinesen klaut?
Sagt doch, rechnet sich nicht.
Das nächste ist
dann,
das nächste ist, dass die
wahrscheinlich dann Funktionen
mit Abo freischalten lassen und
sowas. Ich sehe es schon kommen.
Du musst dann, demnächst ist nur noch
zwei Jahre Vision inklusive, danach
brauchst du ein Abo.
Natürlich nicht mitten in der Wohnung haben
und habe sie deshalb ein bisschen in der Ecke
versteckt, wo immer ein Stuhl direkt
davor steht. Und das ist kein Problem.
Der Roboter findet da trotz Stuhl rein
und raus, dauert halt nur ein bisschen länger.
Da hat meiner teilweise ein bisschen Probleme mit.
Ich habe den Roboter in den ersten Wochen meist fahren lassen, wenn ich nicht zu Hause war
und das hat
oft geklappt, aber oft auch nicht.
Dann bekam ich eine Benachrichtigung auf Smartphone,
Roboter hängen fest und kann sie nicht selbstständig
befreien. Ja, dann hätte er jetzt
Remote steuern können und ihn rauslotsen.
Habe ich gedacht, dass ich ja die
Fernsteuerfunktion benutze. Ne, das geht wahrscheinlich
nicht, weil der hängt fest.
Ich denke, der hängt fest
und du kriegst ihn auch mit der Fernsteuerfunktion nicht raus.
Manchmal fahren die über Stuhl,
Stuhlfüße drüber und hängen dann mit dem
Reifen in der Luft und so.
Was ich für
einen habe, ich habe einen Roborock,
S5, glaube ich.
Oh.
Real Frieto.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Ja, ja.
Da hatte meiner mit meinem
Teppich im Wohnzimmer Probleme. Das hat auch
so Franzen an der Seite.
Da hat er schon öfters
mal Probleme mit gehabt.
Und dann ist es halt vorbei. Dann muss ein Mensch
helfen. Aus diesem Grund versucht der Roboter
Schuhe weiträumig zu umfahren.
Mit seiner KI-Erkennung
klappt das sogar einigermaßen.
Was noch schlimmer wäre, als ein verhäterter
Schnürsenkel, wäre ein Haustier
Kackhaufen. Logisch.
Weil wenn das Teil da durchfährt, dann ist das nicht so gut.
Wenn das Teil da durchfährt, dann ist das nicht so gut.
Wenn das Teil da durchfährt, wird das halt in der ganzen Wohnung verteilt.
Die KI-Erkennung reagiert
deshalb besonders sensibel auf
Haustierschmutz. Nur leider habe ich
einen Teppich, der... Was haben die alles für Haustiere?
Also
meine Katzen kacken in der Regel
nicht irgendwo in die Wohnung.
...die er eingewebt hat.
Tja. Man kann aber auch dann
manuell in der App sagen, das ist kein Haustierschmutz.
Das soll so. Und das speichert
der Roboter dann auch. Und dann
wird er davon nicht mehr so aus dem Konzept gebracht.
Bisschen lustig. Diese ziemlich
große Holzkugel ist laut
Overwatch-KI auch Haustierschmutz.
Was soll das bitte für ein Haustier sein?
Ein Tyrannosaurus Rex?
Gewisserweise
schwierig jetzt zu unterscheiden, oder?
Was man aber ganz klar sagen muss, solche unruhigen
Bereiche mit Mustern auf dem Boden
oder Hindernisse dauern lange.
Da fährt der Roboter zumindest von außen
betrachtet total unlogisch drauf rum.
Hier mal ein Beispiel mit drei
kleinen Hindernissen. Schaukelpferd,
Stoffmaus und Plastikspielzeug.
Fast eine halbe Stunde dauert nur,
das Saugen dieses Bereichs. Ohne die
Hindernisse fährt der Sauger immer noch
sehr unsystematisch hin und her, braucht
aber nur die Hälfte. Also das hat bei meinem
wirklich gut geklappt.
Der hat einfach so Bahnen durch den
Raum gezogen. Am schnellsten
klappt es auf einfarbigen
Uniformen-Untergründen. Für diesen hier
sichtbaren Bereich braucht der Sauger nur acht
Minuten und macht in der Zeit sogar zwei
Durchläufe. Das ist richtig nice, wenn
man gerade ein bisschen Putzfimmel hat. Dann
drückt man auf zweimal und dann
wird der Bereich zuerst horizontal,
abgefahren und dann vertikal. Damit
erzeugt man im Wohnungsplan in der App
so ein Muster. Super befriedigend. Diese
Wohnungspläne erzeugt der Roboter
übrigens von selbst. Ein einzelner
Reinigungsvorgang reicht ja schon. Das konnte
meiner auch schon. Meiner ist ja quasi der
Vor-Vorgänger von dem. Das ging auch
schon. Da konntest du... Fancy 3D-Darstellung.
Das fand ich auch cool, weil das hatte
man dann alles im Browser und konnte
sich das alles im Webinterface angucken
anstatt in der offiziellen App. Mit der
Zeit werden die Pläne
dann theoretisch immer genauer. Das
klappte bei mir auch ein paar Wochen
lang gut. Ich muss noch mal kurz was gucken.
Home Assistant Roborock S7. Da gibt es
doch mittlerweile halbwegs eine
gescheite Integration, oder? Was braucht
man? Hax? Den Cloud Map Extractor.
Ach, für die Bilder, oder wie? Also was
braucht man? Die App? Schreib halt, was Sache
ist. Ja, simpel. Ah ja, okay. Die Xiaomi-App-Integration
braucht man dann. Die Cloud-Integration.
Ja, okay, okay. Es widerstrebt mir, es
widerstrebt mir einfach, dass ich so ein
Cloud-Only... Irgendwann fing das System dann
sogar an, die Räume korrekt automatisch
zu benennen. Also Schlafzimmer, Esszimmer,
Badezimmer. Das ist cool, aber es gab
auch immer wieder Fehler. Am seltsamsten
war, dass ich irgendwann einen Bereich
einfach seitlich umdrehte auf der Karte
und der Roboter dann wirklich komplett
falsch fuhr und auch die... Das hatte ich im
Wohnzimmer. Ich hatte was ähnliches im
Wohnzimmer. Der Roboter, also der
Staubsauger, der war durch den
Fernseher, durch das Display vom Fernseher,
wahrscheinlich weil es irgendwie
reflektiert hat oder so, war der verwirrt,
sodass mit jedem Hin- und Zurückfahren
wurde das Wohnzimmer
auf der Map größer. Also der ist nie
fertig geworden.
Der ist hin und zurück gefahren und dann
ist das Wohnzimmer immer gewachsen. Also
bei ihm in der Logik, ja. Und
dementsprechend ist er mehr oder weniger
auch immer an den gleichen Stellen
aufwärts und abwärts gefahren, weil das
Wohnzimmer quasi gewachsen ist, während
er gefahren ist. Ja, das hat ihn verwirrt.
Aber das gab ein Update und dann war's
gut. Dann war alles in Ordnung.
Real Estate. Zumindest in der App.
Was ja jetzt nicht so schlimm ist. Beim
Neuerstellen passierten allerdings wieder
ein paar komische Fehler. So war nach
Meinung des Roboters das Badezimmer nur
abgedroht. Ach ja, und was früher auch nervig war bei den
Xiaomi-Dingern, die haben die Map
teilweise komplett vergessen. Wenn du sie
hochgenommen hast, hast du sie ausgeleert
und wieder auf die Ladestation gesetzt,
dann haben teilweise sie die Map vergessen.
Wie es eigentlich war, der Rest war Flur und das ist
jetzt auch nicht so schlimm, aber ich
benutze schon häufiger die Funktion, den
Roboter gezielt nur in einen Raum zu
schicken. Das geht da natürlich nicht,
wenn die Räume falsch gemappt sind.
Glücklicherweise kann man das in der App
einigermaßen manuell gerade ziehen, aber
es wäre schon schön, wenn das irgendwann
sicherer klappen würde. Falls ihr euch
wundert, was in den Kartenansichten
diese schraffierten Bereiche sind, das
sind kleine Läufer und Teppiche. Das ist
wichtig, dass der Roboter die App... Ach, das meint er.
Das hier sind Türen. Das ist, wenn er...
Das hier ist, wenn er durch die Tür
durchgucken konnte. Das ist hier, wo er
durch die Tür durchguckt.
Da kommt er durch die Tür. Das ist hier, wo er durch die Tür durchguckt.
Da kommt er durch die Tür durchgucken. Da ist er aber nie reingefahren.
Vielleicht war es auch nicht die Tür,
sondern der Flur? Wo es den Flur geht?
Bereiche sind, das sind kleine Läufer und
Teppiche. Das ist wichtig, dass der
Roboter die erkennt. Schließlich will
man da keinen nassen Lappen drüberziehen.
Das klappt tatsächlich gut. Sobald der
Roborock auf einem Teppich fährt, zieht
er den Lappen automatisch hoch, sodass
der Teppich trocken bleibt. In dem ganzen
halben Jahr... Das ist eine gute, gute
Funktion. ... zu beklagen. Was ich
allerdings nervig fand, ungefähr mit der
Hälfte der Teppiche in meiner Wohnung
kam der Roborock nicht zurecht. Die
schob der immer nur zur Seite. Auch diese
Anti-Rutsch-Streifen unten drunter
brachten nichts. Die Problem-Teppiche
musste ich also vor der Reinigung immer
manuell weglegen. Die Saug- und
Wischleistung fand ich okay, auch wenn
vor allem an den Rändern und Ecken
manchmal ein Krümelchen liegen blieb.
Für ca. 70 Quadratmeter Reinigungsfläche
braucht der Roboter in meiner Wohnung
rund 80 Minuten. Vom Gefühl her würde ich
sagen, dass der Roborock S7 Max V
ungefähr drei Viertel so gut saugt wie
mein normaler Kabelsauger und
der Wischer etwa halb so gut wischt wie
ich mit einem normalen Feudel. Das liegt aber
auch daran, dass ich den Roborock immer ohne
Reinigungsmittel verwendet habe, denn
mit meinen unversiegelt... Habe ich, habe ich auch,
ich, ich, also wie gesagt, ich, ich habe noch
gar nicht diese Wischfunktion verwendet,
aber wenn, würde ich es auch nicht. Mit
Spülmittel oder so, keine Ahnung. Wäre mir
auch nix. ... in Böden, war ich mir da echt
unsicher. Außerdem sagt Roborock, man
solle unbedingt das Original-Roborock-Reinigungszeug
verwenden. Ja, bla bla bla. Ja und das habe ich nur mal...
Ich habe AliExpress zum Kaufen gefunden und das fand ich ein bisschen komisch.
Reinigungsmittel aus China. AliExpress, ah, ist klar.
So fand ich das ein bisschen problematisch.
Verbrauchsmaterialien wie die
Staubsaugerbeutel und die Wischtücher
gibt es nur in wenigen Shops zu kaufen
und dann sind sie oft auch nicht klar
benannt. Ich hatte mir beispielsweise neue
Staubsaugerbeutel bestellt, die hießen
Roborock Original S7 Staubsaugerbeutel für S7
Absaugstation. Sind aber die falschen, die
sind nämlich für die Absaugstation ohne
Wischwasserfunktion. Oh man. Das muss man wissen, dass
ist die auch... Das, das ist, das sieht
den Scheiß nicht hinkriegen. Muss ich nicht.
Apropos Verbrauchsmaterialien. Eigentlich
sollte die App einem sagen, was man wann
tauschen oder reinigen muss. Einige Sachen
werden auch tatsächlich über Sensoren
erkannt, wie zum Beispiel, wenn der
Schmutzwassertank voll ist. Andere Sachen
funktionieren über einen mitlaufenden
Timer. Wenn x Arbeitsstunden um sind, wird
einem der Austausch empfohlen, zum
Beispiel der Seitenbürste. Und Roborock
bewirbt ja die Station als
selbstreinigend, als mehrere Wochen
autark laufend. Ich dachte deshalb
anfangs, ja geil, leere ich den Bums halt aus,
wenn er voll ist,
und sonst muss ich mich nicht umkommen.
Aber das war nicht so eine gute Idee. Der
Schmutzwassertank stank nämlich von ganz kurzer Zeit
erbärmlich. Also wirklich so wie im Puhstamm. Das kann ich mir vorstellen.
Alter. Ganz ehrlich, ich würde den auch
nicht wischen lassen bei mir. Ich habe eh
überall Teppich, außer im Bad. Da ist das
mit Wischen eh nix. Und da reicht's, wenn er
auch mal einfach drüber sorgt. Also nicht
mit geschlossenem Tank, sondern wenn man
den aufgemacht hat. Oben drauf
schwammen ekelige Tüten. Ja, und auch in der
Station selbst war es richtig ekelig. Als ich
einmal aus dem Urlaub zurückkam und da
mal reinschaute. Ja, guck mal. Igitt, oder?
Dass man da sauber machen muss. Okay, ich
hätte da auch drauf kommen können, aber
ich dachte halt, dass mir das die App
schon mitteilt, weil die ja auch sonst bei
jedem Piep sich meldet. Zum Beispiel, dass
ich die völlig sauberen Sensorenreinigung
reinigen soll und sowas. Was mit dem
Gammelgeruch übrigens etwas geholfen hat,
war ein Schnapsglas-Essigessenz im
Frischwasser. Aber auch nur ein bisschen, denn leider
wird der nasse Lappen nicht getrocknet,
wenn der Roboter fertig ist. Das können
Konkurrenzmodelle besser. Die haben da so
einen Föhn eingebaut. Kurz vor Erklärung dieses Videos
poppte in der Roborock-App übrigens auf
einmal eine Trocknungsfunktion auf. Ich
hatte mich schon gefreut, aber man
benötigt dafür ein zusätzliches
Trocknungsmodul für über 100 Euro, das es
bislang nur in China gibt. Ja, und wenn der
nasse Lappen da unten einfach drin liegt,
wird er dann natürlich ziemlich leicht
stockig und die Pilze vermehren sich.
Deshalb muss man den Lappen eigentlich
nach jedem Lauf manuell abheben. Wie gesagt, ich
würde ihn auf keinen Fall wischen lassen.
Hätte ich jetzt, habe ich schon beim Auen
nicht gemacht. Und den Frischwasserbehälter muss man
mindestens einmal die Woche auslernen, würde
ich so über den Daumen gepeilt sagen, auch
wenn er noch lange nicht voll ist. Ja, aber
ihr merkt schon, wenn man da eh ständig
dran rumfummeln muss, wozu braucht man
das Fire HD? Nee, hat alles funktioniert.
... eure Selbstreinigungsstation. Da kann man
auch eigentlich direkt den Lappen... Da ist es, guck, guck,
hier, da. Da ist es. ... per Hand reinigen und halt
das Wischwasser in den Sauger direkt rein.
Wischtuchhalterung angebracht. Ja, habt ihr
recht, würde ich auch so sehen, aber ich
muss sagen, was ich auf jeden Fall als
deutliche Arbeitserleichterung empfand,
dass der Staubbehälter automatisch
geleert wird. Ja. Dazu hätte ich nämlich echt
keinen Bock, das ständig manuell machen zu müssen.
Das... Dafür finde ich die Station also super.
Das finde ich gut, ja. Man könnte dafür die reine
Absaugstation nehmen, also die ohne Wasser.
Die kostet einzeln 280 Euro, also ein paar
hundert Euro weniger als... Ganz ehrlich,
aber 1000 Euro ist schon mal echt ne
Hausnummer. Dafür kriege ich fast
ein neues Hoftor. Von mir getestete
Ultrastationen, aber die habe ich nicht
testen können. Ach ja, woran man auch immer
denken sollte, immer nach ein paar
Reinigungsläufen die Haupt- und
Seitenbürste auf Haare untersuchen. Da
sind leider oft ganze Büschel eingerollt.
Staubsaugerroboter-Veteranen sagen jetzt,
ja klar, das weiß man doch. Also ich
wusste das vorher nicht und finde das
auch nicht sehr elegant, immer in so Haaren
da rum zu zwirbeln. Okay, das betrifft
natürlich vor allem Leute mit langen
Haaren und oder Haustieren, aber... Wie kommt man
jetzt auf...
mit meinem Hoftor-Macher? Also mein Fazit
nach einem halben Jahr. Mich nervt vieles
an dem Teil, aber was ich absolut safe
sagen kann, der Roboter hat dafür gesorgt,
dass meine Böden sauberer sind als
vorher. Das liegt aber auch daran, dass
es einfach Spaß macht, dem Ding bei der
Arbeit zuzugucken. Aber vor allem habe
ich das irgendwann als Challenge gesehen,
die Wohnung immer so vorzubereiten, dass
der Sauger alle Zimmer problemlos
durchfeudelt und saugt, ohne sich
festzufahren. Ein paar Minuten dauert das
immer, die Teppiche entsprechend
einzuklappen, mögliche
Schlingpflanzen aus dem Weg zu räumen,
VR-Headsets aufzuheben, etc. Aber
gleichzeitig räume ich dann halt auch ein
bisschen auf. Und es ist also so eine Art
Gamification. Die Belohnung, dass ich die
Wohnung aufräume, ist, dass der Roboter da
problemlos durchfahren kann und ich mir
das in dieser coolen Video-Ansicht
anschauen kann, wenn ich will. Und ich danach
glänzende Böden habe. Also glänzend jetzt
ohne Reinigungsmittel nicht unbedingt,
aber schon einigermaßen sauber. Ich muss
auch wirklich sagen, dass ich das Teil
sehr ungern wieder zurückgebe. Ich habe mich
echt dran gewöhnt.
Aber ich weiß nicht, ob ich 1.400 Euro
dafür ausgeben würde. Dafür sind viele
Sachen einfach noch nicht gut genug. Vor
allem die ganze Schmutzwasser-Pilz-
Problematik finde ich unangenehm. Ich
würde mir da zumindest eine Erinnerung
wünschen, einmal pro Woche das Teil sauber zu machen.
Ich werde erst mal
wieder beim 0815 Standard-Staubsauger bleiben.
Wie sind da eure Erfahrungen mit Saug- und oder
Wischrobotern? Ja, wie gesagt, ich hatte
einen und jetzt bin ich wieder beim normalen
Staubsauger. Und ich denke, dabei
bleibt es auch erst mal.
Mal gucken. Also wenn es mal was gibt mit
Absaugstation, nur trocken, ich will nichts
wischen oder so. Also nur, also nur
saugen. Also wenn es mal was gibt mit
Absaugstation und dann irgendwie noch zu
einem halbwegs normalen Preis und dass es
nicht nur mit der offiziellen App und
nur China-Chinesen-Cloud geht, dann
überlege ich mir vielleicht noch mal. Aber
das wird wahrscheinlich in nächster Zeit
eh nicht passieren. Es wird mir ja schon reichen, wenn es
irgendwie wenig. Es müsste noch nicht mal so gut
sein. Es würde reichen, wenn es schon weniger
aufwendig ist, so. Aber war es bei meinem halt
nicht. Okay, dann ersetzt China-Cloud durch
Cloud an sich. Aber ich will keinen
Staubsaugerroboter, der nur funktioniert,
wenn man irgendwo seine Daten in irgendeine
Cloud lädt und in eine chinesische Cloud
nach China meine Daten laden will ich
noch weniger. Ich würde es auch nicht unbedingt jetzt
irgendwie eine cloud in die usa laden wollen auch nicht eine in hier aber in
china cloud ehrlich gesagt noch lieber der saugt nicht besser als du mit so
normalen hand nicht mit normalen staubsauger halt nicht ein
handstaubsauger diesen normalen staubsauger gibt die saugen viel besser
als der roboter ja ich verstehe auch nicht warum das unbedingt zwangsläufig
über die cloud gehen muss es ist jetzt ja nicht so als hätten die irgendwelche
services die das zwingend erforderlich machen würden dass sein staubsauger
roboter nur über die cloud kommuniziert aber ja so ist es halt nicht mal
mittlerweile muss muss auch schon das heizungs thermostat teilweise in die
cloud am schlimmsten finde ich mittlerweile diese sache was bei kameras
abgeht du hast eine kamera ja die vollkommen
der normal ist und dafür geeignet ist quasi lokal zu streamen aufzunehmen was
auch immer aber nein die versuchen dann irgendwie das stream nur über die
offizielle
app zu machen und dann muss das ganze die aufnahmen müssen ja auch über die
cloud gehen so dass du den cloud speicherplatz abo kaufen mussten so was
von der kamera die bei mir im hof hängt ganz im ernste kamera die bei mir im
hof hängt bei mir im wlan oder bei mir im netzwerk die soll gefällig streamen
dahin wo ich will und aufnehmen dahin wo ich will der sie muss ja gar nicht
selbst aufnehmen die mussten stream bereitstellen und ist mir aufnahme
kümmere ich mich dann darum also reolink habe ich ein paar die
die spreading aus etads stндんだretchig sind echt geil ne man nach nein ich
könnte kaufen sie ja ist es bei der st limaion ist es beim easily cd einfach
die sind jetzt nicht sonderlich geil aber die sind relativ günstig und preisleistung.de ist wirklich okay ich habe drei sicht 아닌st erzähle jedoch drei störte habe ich von denen und dann noch 22 geflashte aber nicht von demo links sondern von white Ninaié spiders.me古aten Modern Das M działert die website und webapp sollte über dieP乐 fahren – classicIntel singers.com geflasht mit custom f
überflaschen, weil die haben standardmäßig schon
RTSP,
Zugriff, Webinterface und alles,
was man so braucht. Ja, die
Reolink-Dinger sind tatsächlich ganz okay, wenn es
darum geht.
Brauchst keine Cloud.
Weder China-Cloud noch andere Cloud.
So, ich geh jetzt
was essen, Leute. Pippo-Fett.
Hat ja heute alles ganz gut
funktioniert zur Abwechslung.
Falsches Emote, Alter.
Fick dich weg, du Homie.
Sonst gastriere ich dir die...
Das hatten wir schon lange nicht mehr.
Okay.
So, letzter Blick aufs Tablet.
Hat alles getan.
Pog.
Zack. Tablet zu.
Tablet zu.
Home Assistant
VM. Aus.
Stand by.
Alles klar, Leute. Wir sehen uns. Macht's gut. Bis dann.
Ciao.